ich bin etwas später ich wollte normalerweise schon um eine halbe stunde anfangen aber ich
habe überlegt ich fahre noch eine runde fahrrad hier auf meinem smart smart trainer obwohl das
workout angeblich nur 45 minuten dauern soll habe ich irgendwie keine ahnung eine stunde 15 oder so
gebraucht wahrscheinlich weil ich zwischendurch nicht mehr konnte und das ding dann den timer
hat einfach nicht weiter laufen lassen ich weiß es nicht genau es hat auf jeden fall länger gedauert
als da gestattet das teilweise echt brutal ich sage euch leute wenn ihr nicht geübt seid und das
ding erzählt euch dann von irgendwas 280 watt über vier minuten zu fahren da denkt ihr euch
auch nur keck weight alter ich weiß nicht was du im kopf hast also ist so ein ding wo man sein
fahrrad drauf stellen kann und die kette dran macht das ist ein wahoo kickel so ein ding ist
das guck so ein teil genauso da macht man sein fahrrad dran und ein tritt dann tritt man da in
die so sieht das dann aus naja zumindest war das deutlich anstrengender ich habe
ich muss sagen also seit ich angefangen habe das fahrrad zu fahren und regelmäßig zu rennen
ich weiß jetzt erst die ganzen also weltrekorde und und profi zahlen die man manchmal so sieht
irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise einzuschätzen wie komplett außerhalb des möglichen dass für die
leute liegt so krass man ja habe ich habe ich also ich habe einen fiat 500 und den habe ich
tatsächlich ziemlich genau jetzt schon ein jahr ein bisschen über ein jahr ich habe den ende
august gekauft 2022 also sprich habe ich dann so ein jahr zwei monate also also ich würde ihn
wieder kaufen das einzig doofe ist was ich jetzt hatte ist dass die das ist irgendwie ganz komische
geräusche macht
an der bremse links aber das wieder weg ja keine ahnung als komisches super leise gewesen aber nachdem
ich auch weiß wie die cpu auslastung von meinem pc ist anhand der luftgeschwindigkeit höre ich auch
komische geräusche an meinem auto also insofern sehr gut champ ich bin echt im arsch jetzt ist
was ich weiß ich kann sagen wollte vielleicht mal wieder zeit für youtube-video kann das sein was ich gerade sagen wollte kann das sein was ich gerade sagen wollte bin jetzt mal wieder zeit für ein youtube-video kann das sein mal so ein bisschen was das war, war super.
Also auf Keck-Weight-Basis.
Also so langsam.
Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt genau zwei Monate kein YouTube-Video hochgeladen.
Es wird echt mal wieder Zeit.
Aber wie gesagt, ich würde es wieder kaufen, das Auto.
Jetzt kommen wieder manche da.
Oh, Max, das hört sich aber nicht überzeugend an.
Keine Ahnung, wie ich es überzeugender sagen soll.
Ja, man kann ja immer reininterpretieren.
Viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Wenn man selbst die Sache gut findet, interpretiert man rein.
Oh ja, der Max findet es ganz toll.
Wenn man es scheiße findet, interpretiert man rein.
Oh, der hätte lieber was anderes gekauft.
Aber ich kann euch nur sagen, wie es ist.
Also ich würde mir den wieder kaufen.
Den Fiat 500 G.
Also ich weiß es jetzt erst richtig einzuschätzen.
Es ist so heftig.
Wenn man zum Beispiel weiß, dass der Marathon-Weltrekord einfach mal über 41 irgendwas Kilometer doppelt so schnell rennt, wie ich 5 Kilometer.
Ist schon richtig krass.
Und ich bin danach dead.
Ich bin komplett im Arsch.
Und er macht das einfach über 2 Stunden für 42 Kilometer.
Moin Patrick.
52 Kilometer.
Massive Subscription hier.
Und wie laufen deine Kletterambitionen?
Ich habe noch im Hinterkopf, dass du irgendwie angefangen hast, Kletterstelz zu machen.
Ich war mal kurz.
Update für meine 4M.
4M-Update ist nie verkehrt.
Ja, schick mal rüber.
Was hältst du davon, als Software-Engineer in die Schweiz zu gehen?
Zum Beispiel Google die Verdienung.
Naja, kommt drauf an, ob du so flexibel bist und in die Schweiz willst.
Also, wenn du da nicht gebunden bist und sowas.
Ja, kannst du in den Chat schreiben.
Aber keine G-Bait-Links posten, sonst müssen wir Modgis, müssen wir nicht timeouten.
Also, keine Dickpics oder sowas jetzt.
Ich gucke es mir eh in der Vorschau erst an auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Ja, einfach in den Chat.
Aspicon.
Okay, das klingt tatsächlich nicht nach G-Bait.
Stell dir vor, mit deinem Job kannst du wirklich was in dieser Welt bewegen.
Boah, das ist immer so.
Das sind so riesengroße, große Worte immer, ja.
Ich mach mal kurz, ich mach mal kurz Update von meiner VM.
Muss mal sein.
Ja.
Und, ey, ohne Scheiß, wenn ich Probleme hab, muss das jetzt gerade noch fertig los werden.
Wenn ich Probleme habe, ja, auf meinem Trainer hier daheim über vier Minuten lang 280 Watt zu treten,
das krieg ich nicht, das krieg ich nicht.
Also, das krieg ich einmal hin.
Dann kann ich eigentlich absteigen.
Und für den Tag muss ich mich nicht mehr draufsetzen.
Und ich dann irgendwie sehe, dass du irgendwelche Profis hast, die mit irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 450 Watt den Berg hochballern.
Da denkst du dir auch, das ist das...
Wie geht das eigentlich, Mann?
Das ist super krass, Alter.
Ich konnte das vorher überhaupt nicht einschätzen.
Jetzt auch nicht richtig.
Aber es ist so heftig, was die da teilweise abziehen, ey.
Ja.
Wäre ja ein bisschen sinnverfehlt, ja.
By the way, du bist ja schon alt, so hast du irgendeinen Altersversorgerplan.
Ich hab ein ETF, ja.
Also, was ist ein?
Ist ja nicht so, als hätte man...
Also, es besteht ja aus mehreren Sachen.
Aber auch nur, weil ich zu faul bin, irgendwie was anderes zu machen.
Ich hab einen...
Moment, wo ist mein Handy?
Äh, wo ist mein Handy?
Ah, Sekunde.
Sekunde, ich kann's euch sagen.
Ich hab einen...
Die Stonks sind aber nicht so gut gerade, deswegen will ich da gar nicht reingucken.
Ja.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Aber ohne Mist, Leute.
Es bringt echt was.
Also, ich merke, dass ich hab...
Ah, Face not recognized, Leute.
Face leak fürs Handy.
Oh, heute gab's Stonks.
Heute ging's hoch wieder ein bisschen.
Oh, tatsächlich.
Das ist tatsächlich wieder minimal im Plus.
Nachdem's übelst runtergegangen ist den letzten Monat.
Ja, ich seh's gerade.
Es ist...
Es ist tatsächlich ein bisschen hochgegangen.
Ja, also ich hab...
Ich hab Stonks.
Ja.
Da bezahle ich ab und zu mal was ein.
In der Hoffnung, dass es dann in ein paar Jahren noch mehr ist.
Arzi, danke schön für den Sub.
Und Patrick, danke für den Sub.
Und falls ihr irgendwas vergessen habt...
Sorry, Leute.
Guck mal hier, komm.
Leute, vier Minuten für einen Sub, das kriegen wir noch auf die Reihe.
Ja, dann freue ich mich.
Und Bezos kann auch mal ins Weltall fliegen.
Das hat allen geholfen.
Und ihr kriegt Porgas Emotes im Chat.
Wo ich übrigens noch...
Noch vier verschiedene...
Dankeschön.
Danny CS Porg-Subscription-Liste.
Das hatten wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Also heute geht's wirklich hoch, ja.
Ich hab's auch gerade gesehen.
Ja, wie gesagt, also...
Das mach ich.
So, ich schmeiß jetzt mal die Updates an.
Von der VM.
Und dann gucken wir uns die Stellenanzeige an von...
Jack Jackson.
Muss ich mal vorstellen.
Ich packe maximal über ein paar Minuten...
Auf meinem hier Fahrrad...
Packe ich maximal für ein paar Minuten so...
2,5...
Watt pro Kilogramm.
Das kann ich aber jetzt auch keine Stunde durchfahren oder so.
Also vielleicht...
Vielleicht...
Vielleicht fünf Minuten.
Dann bin ich dead.
Und...
Die bei der Tour de France ballern...
Gut, die wiegen auch nur die Hälfte von mir.
Aber trotzdem.
Die bei der Tour de France ballern...
Mit 6,5 Watt das Kilogramm den Berg hoch.
Das ist komplett unmenschlich.
Das kann man...
Ja, ey, Leute.
Ich könnte alles Doping der Welt fressen.
Und ich würde nicht...
Drei...
Watt das Kilogramm schaffen.
Ihr könntet mich...
Alles.
Pillen, Spritzen, Zäpfchen...
Was gibt's noch?
Zum Inhalieren...
Augen, Tropfen, alles.
Das wird nichts helfen.
Ja.
Plus irgendwie noch...
Alle...
Alle zwei Minuten so eine...
So eine Adrenalinspritze oder so.
Selbst das wird nicht reichen bei mir.
Gewicht geliehen.
Ja, Gewicht müssen wir nicht liegen.
Gewicht habe ich schon oft genug geleakt.
Also aktuell ist Gewicht...
Gewicht...
Ne, ich weiß es nicht ganz aktuell, ich habe mich letztens draufgestellt, da hatte ich aber Hose, Socken, T-Shirt, alles an, da waren es 93, aber normalerweise ist es morgens so um die 91.
Man sollte sich ja immer ein bisschen vergleichbar wiegen, so nach dem Motto, morgens in Unterhose oder morgens nackig oder irgendwie so, sonst ist das schlecht vergleichbar.
Also so um die 90 ist es gerade. Angefangen vor eineinhalb Jahren habe ich es mal mit 108,5, Körpergröße 174, also immer noch massive Pipo-Fett, aber nicht mehr ganz so schlimm wie vor eineinhalb Jahren.
Dafür muss ich sagen, durch das Regel, also erstmal habe ich durch regelmäßig bewegen deutlich schneller abgenommen als durch weniger essen.
Weniger essen, ihr kennt mich, weniger essen ist sehr schwierig. Ich fresse halt immer gerne, wenn es schmeckt so viel.
Also das einzige, was bei mir wirklich geholfen hat zum Abnehmen, ist vielleicht ein bisschen weniger essen, aber eigentlich auch nicht so wirklich.
Vielleicht ein bisschen gesünder essen, aber auch nicht so wirklich. Vielleicht ganz, ganz, ganz minimal als Seiteneffekt.
Das einzige, was bei mir wirklich geholfen hat, ist täglich eineinhalb Stunden bewegen. Ohne Scheiß, das ist das einzige, was bei mir geholfen hat.
Und jetzt seit irgendwie so...
Also zweieinhalb Monaten, seitdem ich regelmäßig rennen gehe und Fahrrad fahren, hat sich am Gewicht ein bisschen was getan.
So sagen wir mal so eineinhalb Kilo vielleicht, ja. Aber ich bin viel fitter insgesamt, das merke ich auch.
Also ich komme eigentlich bei alltäglichen Sachen mittlerweile null außer Puste.
Also ich kann echt nur empfehlen, ab und zu mal ein bisschen bewegen ist wirklich nicht so schlecht.
Das ist quasi der Giga-Chat-Move.
Ich habe ein kaputtes Fahrrad, weil ich umgefahren wurde vor zwei Wochen am Samstag.
Aber für einen Heimtrainer tut das noch. Und der Heimtrainer hat halt auch so eine Leistungsmessung drin.
7LQRS, danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, vorletzten Samstag hat mich ein Auto auf dem Fahrradweg umgefahren.
Not so pog. Mini-pog quasi.
Oder was ist das Gegenteil? Monka-S eher.
Monka-Steer. Monka-Steer ist glaube ich das Richtige, ja.
Richtig, deswegen habe ich mir da gar keine so viele Gedanken zugemacht.
Wenn ich jetzt am Trainieren bin und nicht so sehr abnehme, aber dafür ein paar Muskeln kriege an den Stellen, die zu den Sportarten passen,
ist mir das auch mehr als recht.
Also wo ich das wirklich extrem gemerkt habe ist, als ich angefangen habe zu rennen,
ja so ungefähr alle zwei Tage, so.
Also wenn ich schnell renne, dann nur fünf Kilometer, ansonsten ist meine Standardrunde so 6,2 Kilometer.
Und also was ich extrem gemerkt habe, die ersten Male, wo ich gelaufen bin, also die ersten eineinhalb, zwei Wochen, alter Leute, ey ich hatte...
Also bei den ersten Malen haben mir einfach nur die Beine und die Waden wehgetan.
Das war aber gar nicht so schlimm, das ging dann nach ein, zwei Tagen wieder weg.
Das war so ganz am Anfang, so die ersten drei, vier Mal Rennen.
Was dann war, und das hat tatsächlich bestimmt fast einen Monat gedauert, bis sich das jetzt ein bisschen gelegt hat, ist,
mir hat das Schienbein übertrieben wehgetan.
Immer den Tag, nachdem ich gerannt bin.
Aber ich meine, mein Schienbein ist einfach nicht die Belastung gewöhnt von 90 Kilo, was dann mal so drauf rammt, so im Sekundentakt.
Ja, ich auch nicht, ich auch nicht.
Aber gleich kommen wir zu Stellenanzeigen.
Ich will nur mal gucken, ob meine Frau immer richtig geupdatet hat.
Nix, ganz ehrlich, ich kenne das, ich habe das letzte, du meinst dieses Diabetes-Medikament, ne, nix.
Ganz ehrlich, das Beste, was man machen kann, ist sich mehr bewegen.
Das ist nicht nur gut fürs Abnehmen, weil Abnehmen alleine ist, denke ich mal, nur die halbe Miete.
Du hast die ganzen positiven Nebeneffekte nicht, wenn du nicht durch ein bisschen mehr Bewegen abnimmst.
Du hast weiterhin Rückenprobleme, du hast weiterhin Kopfschmerzen, Nacken, sonst was, Beine, Hintern.
Du bist außer Puste.
Vielleicht ein bisschen weniger, außer Puste, weil du ein bisschen weniger wiegst.
Aber das, also meiner Ansicht nach, und das ist auch das Einzige, was überhaupt je bei mir geholfen hat,
und das funktioniert echt ganz gut, es ist gar nicht so viel weniger Essen oder sonst was,
sondern einfach schlicht und ergreifend mehr Bewegen.
So doof es klingt, ich wusste das, ich wusste das, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich das nicht wusste.
Das weiß, das weiß jeder, ja.
Aber, also der erste Schritt ist erstmal, es zu realisieren, okay, aber das weiß eigentlich niemand.
Das weiß eigentlich jeder.
Der zweite Schritt ist tatsächlich, das zu machen.
Und man muss es gar nicht übertreiben.
45 Minuten mal am Tag ein bisschen spazieren gehen, ist so viel besser als einfach nur hocken.
Ich weiß, ich höre mich an, so wie mein Opa, der mir das früher immer erzählte.
Das ist einfach ein Riesenunterschied.
Wie hast du damals als noch jung warst, neue IT-Themen gelernt?
Gibt es da viele Möglichkeiten, wie Udemy Bücher?
Also ich habe tatsächlich noch relativ viele Bücher gelesen.
Gerade wenn es um Programmiersprachen und sowas ging, so für Ruby, für C-Sharp damals.
Gibt es übrigens immer noch ein ziemlich gutes kostenloses Einstiegs, Einstiegsbuch.
Ja, als Git neu war, hatte ich, habe ich mir auch so ein größeres Buch.
Aber da habe ich tatsächlich noch wirklich, wie nennt man das, Hardcover, ne wie heißt das, so ein richtig echtes Buch halt gekauft.
Mittlerweile lese ich auch ganz gerne noch, nennen wir das mal Fachliteratur, aber dann nur noch als E-Book.
Ey, es hat jeder, es hat...
Es hat jeder, das ist für mich keine großartige Motivation gewesen.
Also ich habe, ich habe nie, bis du das jetzt geschrieben hast, habe ich nicht daran gedacht, so nach dem Motto,
Max, mach mal krasse, krasse Training-Action, dass du mehr Mädels abchecken kannst.
Das, bis zu deinem, das war überhaupt nicht.
Mir ging es wirklich einzig und allein darum und ich glaube, das ist auch der...
Ich meine, hey, jeden, was ihn motiviert, ja.
Wenn es jetzt einen motiviert, so nach dem Motto, ich bewege mich mehr, weil ich dann fett die Weiber abchecken kann.
Alles gut.
Könnte, jeder, was ihn so motiviert, wer ist das, das sage ich gleich.
Aber ich glaube, das Beste ist, wenn man realisiert, dass das unmittelbar und dass das so krass ist, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht,
dass man unmittelbar riesen Vorteile dadurch hat.
Du hast instant, fast, also wenn du anfängst, das sind ein paar Tage, vielleicht ein, zwei Wochen gemacht hast,
du hast instant, instant so keine Kopfschmerzen mehr, nix im Rücken mehr, viel, viel weniger irgendwelche Verspannungen,
die ein paar Tage dauern, nix am Bein, du kannst dich besser konzentrieren, dein Hirn funktioniert besser.
Das merkst du gerade die ersten ein, zwei Wochen, weil der Unterschied so krass ist.
Mittlerweile gewöhnt man sich ja dann, ja.
Und ja, das kann man auch machen.
Leute, das ist eines der Punkte, was mich auch motiviert.
Ich kann jetzt übelst viel fressen, wenn es was gibt, was schmeckt.
Und ich weiß, wenn ich nachher eine Stunde Fahrrad fahre...
oder heute Morgen mal eine Runde Rennen fahre, dann ist das vielleicht nicht ganz weg dadurch, aber fast weg.
Und durch das, was es noch ein bisschen so an Nachwirkungen hat für den Tag, ist es eigentlich weg.
Also im Prinzip, es kann auch motivieren, man kann mehr fressen, ja.
Aber eins muss man sagen, du musst auch mehr fressen, weil du hast Hunger, es fuck.
Also, ohne Mist, seit ich angefangen habe, mich mehr zu bewegen jetzt, ich habe immer, also ich meine, ich hatte vorher schon immer Hunger, ja.
Ich konnte früher, ich konnte immer was futtern.
Aber Leute, ich könnte echt gerade den ganzen Tag fressen.
Aber wo kriegt man die Zeit her, wenn man so voll arbeitet, auch wenn man sieben Tage die Woche hat?
Naja, also ich mache das so.
Mein Ziel ist, wobei ich das noch nicht weiß, ob das langfristig die beste Planung ist.
Also bis, bevor ich angefangen habe mit Fahrradfahren, bin ich einfach jeden Tag, jeden zweiten Tag Rennen gegangen.
Unabhängig davon, ob mir das Schienbein wehgetan oder nicht, ich habe einfach gesagt, auf geht's.
Und ich konnte mich auch bei Scheißwetter und so dazu motivieren.
Jetzt, also gut, wie ich das gemacht habe, war eigentlich ganz einfach.
Ich, jeden zweiten Tag musste nicht viel überlegen.
Du weißt, gestern war es ja nicht, heute musste wieder.
Und ich habe das einfach morgens gemacht.
Morgens ist auf der Arbeit noch nichts los.
Und da gehe ich so um.
Wo gehe ich?
Dann immer so sieben Uhr überlegen, dass ich jetzt kein Mist erzähle.
Ja, so 7.40 Uhr oder so sieben Uhr.
Nee, nee, eigentlich sogar noch ein bisschen früher.
7.30 Uhr vielleicht 7.30 Uhr bis bis 8.20 Uhr, 8.30 Uhr, je nachdem.
Und je nachdem, wie das getimt ist und je nach Woche ist das gar nicht so wild, weil wenn es auf Montag fällt, dann ist es kein Arbeitstag.
Dann ist Dienstag.
Dann ist Mittwoch und Freitag sind nur zwei Arbeitstage.
Und die Zeit passt mal, zumal die Zeit doppelt und dreifach wiederkriegen.
Ich habe vorhin, ohne einzustechen, beispielsweise noch 40 Minuten was auf der Arbeit gemacht, weil unsere tolle Blockchain-Sachen wieder nicht richtig synchronisiert haben.
Und das geht, wenn du das morgens machst, ist eigentlich kein Ding.
Das geht natürlich nur, wenn man Homeoffice machen kann.
Auch vor der Arbeit.
Wenn ich mit dem Zug auf die Arbeit müsste, hätte ich da auch keinen Bock drauf.
Was?
Was ist das?
Äh, hast du Broggers-Stream gemacht oder wie?
Nice.
Oh, jetzt sieht es ja, jetzt sieht es ja richtig advanced aus, langsam.
Web 5.0.
Welches Rad hast du jetzt eigentlich geholt?
Das hier.
Aber das ist kaputt.
Wie gesagt, ich wurde umgefahren auf dem Fahrradweg letzten, vorletzten Samstag.
Doomsweb, danke für den Sub.
Ja, und jetzt?
Also mein Ziel ist, um das jetzt mal abzuschließen und zu den eigentlichen Stellenanzeigen zu kommen, sonst wird das heute nämlich wieder nix.
Mein Ziel ist jetzt, und ich bin mir noch nicht so ganz sicher, dass ich mein Schienbein ein bisschen schonen kann.
Ja, dass ich renne, Fahrrad fahre, Pause mache und dann erst, also quasi, dass ich zwei Tage Pause zwischen dem Rennen habe.
Und Eintracht.
Komplett Pause mache und Eintracht Fahrrad fahre.
Das ist so mein Plan jetzt, ja.
Fahrrad fahren kann auch auf dem Trainer daheim sein, wenn scheiß Wetter ist.
Also quasi, rennen, Fahrrad fahren, Pause, rennen, Fahrrad fahren, Pause, rennen, Fahrrad fahren, Pause.
Also das ist jetzt so, das ist das, was ich mir so überlegt habe, was ich ganz gut, ganz gut integraten kann in mein Daily Business.
Ja, mal gucken, was da alles kommt.
Ja, Leute, wenn ihr Stellenanzeigen habt, die ich mir angucken soll, schickt her, ansonsten suche ich jetzt gleich auch mal.
Ja.
Da gibt es ja immer...
...abenteuerliche Sachen.
Weißt du, wie man an die Edu...
Adobe...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung.
Benutze ich nicht.
Womit hast du die vor allem...
Womit hast du die vor allem laufen?
Vor allem, ja.
Vor allem, ja, habe ich laufen.
Guck da, ja, vor allem, ja.
Mir persönlich auch deutlich lieber als...
...als Virtual Box.
So, dann gucken wir uns das hier doch jetzt mal an.
Entwickeln wir uns so in der Form, ja.
Regelmäßig, hier im Stream auch.
Also eigentlich nur exklusiv.
Ich, ich, ich entwickle unter Windows eigentlich gar nichts mehr.
Ich glaube, ich habe, egal was es ist, von Web-Backend bis Frontend bis CLI-Tools, C-Sharp, Go, Ruby, Bash-Skripts, Python-Gedits, eigentlich exklusiv alles nur in der VR-Motor-Linux.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich, ich lese immer noch ganz gerne E-Books, wenn es um Technik-Sachen geht, wenn es gute gibt zu dem überlegenen Thema.
Zum Beispiel eines der besten Bücher, die ich kenne.
Die ich gelesen habe zum Thema .NET C-Sharp-Entwicklung.
Ich habe vergessen, wie es genau heißt.
Das ist das, das ist das, wo auch John Skeet dran beteiligt war, glaube ich, der, der Stag-Overflow C-Sharp-Master.
Oh, wie hieß das, wie hieß das denn?
Das, das, das war so C-Sharp-Best-Practice-Sachen.
Da habe ich, da habe ich viel draus gelernt.
Was, war es C-Sharp in Depth?
Ne, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Das war echt gut.
Das würde ich mir auch wieder als E-Book holen.
Also man kann aus Büchern, wenn es halt gescheite für das jeweilige Themengebiet gibt,
finde ich teilweise einfacher lernen als mit Tutorials und sonst was, weil es eben gut strukturiert ist und durchdacht.
Ja, da ist ein bisschen mehr Qualitätssicherung dahinter.
So ein, so ein YouTube-Tutorial, wenn ich das sehe, dass, dass es teilweise Leute gibt auf YouTube, die machen dann irgendwie einen 53 Stunden XYZ-Kurs.
Und das meiste davon ist, wie downloade ich mir Visual Studio Code?
Wie downloade ich das, wie mache ich hier, wie installiere ich das?
So Content, 10 Stunden und 53 Stunden, das ist halt einfach unsinnig, ja?
Ich hatte mir, ich hatte mir mal vor einer ganz, vor einer ganz längeren Zeit mal einen Kubernetes-Kurs auf Udemy gekauft, vor, keine Ahnung, 4 Jahren oder so.
Einen, einen Terraform, einen, irgendwie einen Azure Terraform Kubernetes, wie auch immer, Rundumschlag-Kurs.
Und der war so schlecht.
Der war an den Teilen, wo man es wüsste.
Wo man es wissen wollte, zu oberflächlich und dort, wo es nicht interessiert hat, super ausführlich, ja?
Der hat eine halbe Stunde erklärt, wie du irgendwelche CLI-Tools installierst und wo du die herkriegst und was es ist, aber wie man, wie man damit advancede Sachen macht oder interessante Sachen, die man macht, hat er mir wiederum nicht richtig gezeigt.
Also voll für den Arsch, ja.
Also es gibt sicherlich gute Udemy-Kurse, aber, naja, der war nicht gut.
E-Books, wenn es dazu entspricht.
Welche gibt es nicht verkehrt.
Wie das kostenlose C-Sharp-Buch heißt, das kann ich dir sagen.
Hat eben auch einer gefragt.
Galileo Open Book.
C-Sharp.
Ähm.
Das hier.
Das ist zwar, das ist zwar 2012.
Das ist aber nicht schlimm.
Es reicht, also du kannst im Prinzip bis, bis hier.
Inklusive 16.
Den Rest kannst du vergessen.
Aber die Basics sind immer noch ganz, sind immer noch recht relevant.
Natürlich fehlen da viele moderne Konzepte.
Aber zum Einstieg ist es gar nicht so schlecht.
Weil es nicht 100.000 neue Sachen behandelt, sondern wirklich nur die Basics.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Nee, Laufbahn anschreibt sich will ich nicht.
Ich hab, ich hab den Trainer mit dem Fahrrad hinter mir stehen.
So halb hochgeschoben an der Wand das Fahrrad.
Dass er nicht so viel Platz wegnimmt, aber.
Da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen.
Bei, bei Scheibenbremsen.
Dass man das, das Fahrrad nicht, nicht auf den Kopf stellt.
Wobei, eigentlich ist es egal.
Ich behalte das eh nur an dem Trainer.
Da brauch ich keine Bremsen.
So.
Ist ja, was passiert bei dem Unfall?
Ja, mir hat ein paar Tage.
Also ich hab ein bisschen auch, ein bisschen abgeschürft am Arm, am Bein.
Mir hat ein paar Tage die Hüfte und der Arm weh getan.
Aber bisher, jetzt ist eigentlich alles, alles wieder gut.
Ist die Anzeige raus?
Nee, die Anzeige ist nicht raus.
Aber ich hab den, ich hab einen Anwalt beauftragt.
Der sich die Anzeige rausgegeben hat.
Der sich da um die Versicherungs-Sachen kümmert.
Ich hab vom Gutachter schon was.
Der sagt, mein Fahrrad hat einen Restwert von
irgendwie 70 Euro oder so.
Einmal 3500 gekostet.
Und der Anwalt hat auch schon an die Versicherung geschrieben.
Die sollen jetzt endlich mal bezahlen.
So.
Einen mach ich nicht.
Es sieht richtig nice aus, ne?
Gerade mit den neuen Icons hier neben.
Ah ja.
Pog, Pog-Icons.
Sind das AI generierte Stumpnails?
Jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's aber wirklich langsam.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, wir müssen das langsam mal vermarkten, dieses Ding, oder?
Ja, wie gesagt, wie gesagt.
Alles in der VM.
Ich müsste mal updaten, ja?
Weil es jetzt ja angeblich auch Xbox gibt.
Die Daten sind in der VM.
Oh, die kann man ja einfach rauskopieren.
Ja, mach mal.
Wenn die gut ist, sag ich nix.
Wenn die gut ist, dann ist es Schleichwerbung.
Okay, wenn die schlecht ist, dann flame ich euch.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich das Gegenteil.
Klar, warum nicht?
Wenn das irgendwie tut.
Ich habe eh nicht vor, bis zur Rente zu arbeiten.
Und ich denke mal, dass das auch
theoretisch ganz gut möglich ist.
Ich meine, ich verdiene nicht schlecht.
Ich habe ein bisschen Kohle auf der hohen Kante.
Ich habe ein Haus.
Da geht's was.
Ich habe noch Einnahmen von Twitch, YouTube und anderem Zeug.
Ja.
Aber aktuell
sind vier Tage Woche
perfekt für mich.
So.
Hast du? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Darfst du? Darfst du?
Darfst du? Da müssen wir keine Umfrage machen.
Darfst du?
Als Endeavor-OS-Nutzer darfst du dich Arch-User nennen
und uns auch immer darauf hinweisen,
dass du Arch, by the way, usest.
Aber als Manjaro-User nicht.
Die Songs liefen heute anscheinend gut, davor nicht.
Da gibt's nicht viel zu zeigen.
Ein ETF, fertig.
So.
Auf geht's. Dann gucken wir uns das doch mal an.
Boah, meine Augen.
Also bei mir sammeln alle, die Dark-Theme
anbieten für...
Moment, das ist gar nicht das Richtige.
Die Dark-Themes anbieten
für ihre
Bewerbung schon mal Pluspunkte.
Sowas zum Beispiel. Guck mal.
Ah, ne, die auch nicht. Lull.
Moment, ist das... Hatten die denn Dark-Theme?
Wär auch zu einfach.
Du darfst Manjaro, by the way, sagen.
Damit machst du dich aber lächerlich, weil das keiner sagt.
Da outest du dich
als Manjaro-Noob.
Der Gelnhausen-Dude. Union-Investment.
Da kenn ich sogar ein paar Leute, die da arbeiten.
So. Dann gucken wir
uns das doch mal an.
Let's go. Was haben wir denn hier?
Aspicon. Ist der
Jackson-Check noch am
Start?
Oder hab ich zu lang gebraucht, dass der dir die
Stellenanzeige... Ah, du bist noch da. Okay.
Was für ein ETF. Einen...
Den 0815
ETF, den jeder hat.
Einen...
Genau.
Vanguard
FTSE All World
UCITS
ETF USD
Accumulating.
So.
Linux System
Administrator.
Ich verkneif mir meinen Standard-Joke.
Ihr kennt ihn ja alle schon.
Unbefristete Festanstellung.
Vollzeit. Fünf Tage.
40 Stunden. Und flexibel.
Okay.
Deutsch fließen und Englisch gut.
Festgehalt. Zulagen. Benefits.
Reisetätigkeit.
Nein. Das ist schon mal top.
Ich hab eh keinen Bock drauf.
PwC. Oh ne. Auf die hätte ich gar
keinen Bock.
Wir glauben an dich.
Das klingt...
Das klingt nicht schlecht.
Können wir gleich schauen.
Also jetzt gucken wir uns aber erstmal das an.
Also. Was haben wir denn hier?
Das ist Aspicon.
Was macht denn Aspicon?
Oh. Schau mal.
Suse. MonkaS.
Suse. Oh. Windows Server.
Ja gut. Da haben sie die zwei Sachen schon mal richtig
zusammengeschrieben. Suse und Windows Server.
Das war mal um die Leute abzuschrecken.
Ähm.
AWS. Azure.
Oracle Cloud. Docker.
Helm.
Das ist auch random einfach irgendwie zusammengewürfelt.
Oder?
Nun gut.
Okay. Ähm.
Wer ist denn das überhaupt?
Ein Obstkorb.
Ja das ist natürlich schon
das Qualitätskriterium heutzutage.
Okay. Irgendeine Beratungsbude.
Oder?
Also.
Du trägst Verantwortung für Server,
Storage, Virtualisierung
und Netzwerkkomponenten in komplexen Linux Systemen.
Das klingt
ziemlich passend zu einem Linux System Administrator.
Ist ja schon mal was.
Der Titel der Stellenanzeige.
Was mit dem Inhalt zu tun hat?
Da muss man ja schon teilweise echt schon begeistert sein.
Du entwickelst Automatismen
für Prozesse wie zum Beispiel das
Ausrollen, Konfigurieren von Software oder das Updaten
und Patchen von Infrastruktur.
Ja.
Ich find diese Umschreibung ja blöd.
Du entwickelst, okay. Für Prozesse..
Sollen sie einfach schreiben?
Du automatisierst
unsere Infrastruktur oder irgendwie du
du nutzt moderne
ah was weiß ich.
IAC-Tools
Irgendwie ein bisschen
Das ist immer dieses Business-Speak, finde ich
Da irgendwie immer nervig drin
Aber das ist keine schlechte Stellenanzeige, das machen alle so
Aber ich finde es immer
Deutlich sympathischer, wenn das einfach
Auf technischer Ebene, dass du weißt
Okay, oder zumindest
Derjenige, der da sucht
Ist auch derjenige
Der ein bisschen was mit der Stellenanzeige zu tun hat
So, also du entwickelst
Automatisch, das passt auch wunderbar dabei
Zu deinem Repertoire
Ich hoffe ich hab das
Keck keck French
Richtig ausgesprochen
Gehören die Überwachung von Systemen, Fehleranalyse
Probleme, das passt auch
Wunderbar dazu
Du arbeitest an der Weiterentwicklung
Unsere IT
Unsere IT-Sicherheitskonzepte
Und Hardening-Tools
Ja, okay, passt auch
Mit regelmäßigen
Security-Checks deckst du potenzielle
Schwachstellen frühzeitig auf und setzt
Geeignete Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
Security-Checks, das ist sowas
Das schreiben immer alle, dass sie es machen
Aber es will keiner, dass es gemacht wird
Weil das nervt immer nur, so nach dem Motto
Ah, wir sind eh schon ein bisschen in Verzug
Eigentlich müssten wir jetzt noch Test ABC
Machen und wir müssen auch noch Ausfall-Tests
Machen und wir müssen auch noch irgendein Betriebshandbuch
Schreiben und eigentlich müssen wir das und das auch noch
Dokumentieren, ach wisst ihr was
Wir müssen eigentlich morgen live gehen
Lasst das mal alles weg, das wird schon passen
Also so läuft es halt meistens dann
Aber ist ja gut, wenn die es wirklich, wenn die es wirklich ernst meinen
Ja, der Chat wieder, man
Mit Regel, so, also
Du vertiefst, erweiterst und teilst dein Wissen zu unserem
Warum ist die Musik so laut?
Ist gar nicht so laut
Du vertiefst, erweiterst und teilst dein Wissen zu unserem Tech-Stack
Ansible
Shit
Oracle Enterprise Linux
Polka W
Ja, wahrscheinlich aus Lizenzgründen für irgendwelche Datenbanken, vermutlich
Aber ist, ist, ist schon etwas Monka-es
Monka-es?
So, Red Hat Enterprise, Linux for Embryo, okay, das ist relativ, sagen wir mal, normal hier
Ist nix super Außergewöhnliches dabei
Rufbereitschaftsdienste gehören als unverzichtbarer Bestandteil deines verantwortungsvollen Jobs dazu
Sie sind ein zusätzliches Herausforderung, die wir wertschätzen und honorieren
Ja, finde ich nicht schlimm
Gibt's bei uns auf der Arbeit auch, gibt ordentlich extra Kohle, kein Problem mit
Das, also, ob Rufbereitschaftsdienste, ob die gut oder schlecht sind, das hängt eigentlich von genau einem Faktor ab
Wie ordentlich werden Systeme eingeführt, ja?
Also, wenn Systeme live genommen werden, die noch halb kaputt sind, halb in Entwicklung stecken
Und man quasi bei jeder Rufbereitschaft nachts angerufen wird
Dann ist das scheiße
Wenn das alles ordentlich läuft, dass das wirklich die Ausnahme ist, paar mal im Jahr, wenn's hochkommt, dass da irgendwas kommt
Dann ist es gut
Oder es muss wirklich enorm gut sein, wenn es nicht gut ist
Oder es muss nicht gut bezahlt sein
Weil wenn da wirklich gefühlt jede zweite Rufbereitschaft nachts irgendjemand anruft, da hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf
Das ist richtig
Das hab ich auf der Arbeit auch schon angesprochen
Ja, können wir gleich gucken
Weil wir haben ein super weitreichendes Technologie, ähm, wie nennt man das?
Wie heißt denn das so?
Stack?
Portfolio?
Keine Ahnung
Also, wir haben ja alles, ja?
Es gibt, es gibt bei uns auf der Arbeit einfach alles
Wenn ihr ne Frage habt, ob es das bei uns auf der Arbeit irgendwo gibt, aber mir irgendwo auf der Arbeit gibt
Könnt ihr von ausgehen, es gibt's in irgendeiner Art und Weise, ja?
Von SAP bis 50 verschiedene Datenbanken
Okay, zumindest bei Linux sind sie sich relativ einig
Es gibt alles, irgendwie, ja?
Und dematologisch hab ich auch schon gesagt, Leute, also wenn mich jetzt zu System XY nachts einer anruft
Da kann ich nichts dazu sagen
Ich kann mich da drauf einloggen
Ich kann so die Basic Linux Sachen sagen
Gucken, so, laufen Prozesse noch, irgendwelche Logs, die voll gelaufen sind
Hängen irgendwelche Mounts oder so
Ja, ich kann ins Monitoring gucken, ob das was Auslagekräftiges sagt
Mal irgendwie Volltextsuche in den Docs machen, ob da was zusteht zu dem Fehler
Aber wirklich, fundiert aus, Kenmedien, mit jedem System kannst du vergessen
Und ja, das wissen die auch
Finde ich auch gut, dass die das gesagt haben
Und auch meine Team, Teammates auf der Arbeit haben auch gesagt
Das geht uns bei den Systemen ganz genauso
Obwohl wir viel länger da sind schon
Und wir kennen auch nur unsere Systeme richtig gut
Und können bei den anderen nur Basics machen
Das wissen unsere Chefs auch
Das heißt im Endeffekt, und die haben das auch gesagt
Das reicht ihnen, wenn einer da ist, das einschätzen kann
Und Basic Linux Sachen dran vornehmen kann
An den Systemen, wo er halt nicht dafür zuständig ist
Da kriegt man das meiste wahrscheinlich schon aus dem, ja, aus dem Weg geschafft
Und hat ein bisschen Zeit, die Leute anzuklingeln, die vielleicht mehr Ahnung haben
Und dafür, ey, ist okay
Wenn das im Vorfeld alle Beteiligten wissen und sich da drauf committert haben
Dann ist das okay
Ob die sich im Zweifelsfall dran halten
Wenn's denn mal hart auf hart kommt
Das muss ich noch zeigen
Das war bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber zum Beispiel nicht so
Da haben sie auch immer am Anfang erzählt
So nach dem Motto, ja, man kann nicht alles wissen
Aber wenn's dann kaputt gegangen ist, dann sollte man doch alles wissen
Mal gucken, wie da Realität, bin ich mal gespannt drauf
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, ich lande nicht in der Situation, ja
Aber wie da Realität und so in Einklang sind
Aber das bringt uns auch noch ein bisschen mehr
Das bringt ordentlich Kohle, Rufbereitschaft
Also ich würd nicht sagen, ihr fickt euch ins Knie, sondern
Am besten super stabil laufende System plus Rufbereitschaft
Das ist eigentlich die beste Lizenz zum Geld machen, die es gibt
Ja, wie gesagt, bei mir auch so
Aber es scheinen alle fein damit zu sein
Würdest du als jemand, der gerade frisch aus dem Schule kommt, ein LinkedIn oder Xing-Profil machen oder so?
Ja klar, warum nicht?
Also Xing würde ich nicht mehr machen
Xing ist eh schon immer so ein deutsches Ding gewesen
LinkedIn ist eigentlich das, wo's abgeht
Ehrlich gesagt, ich würde es nicht machen, wenn ich das nicht mache
Aber wie gesagt, ist Xing überhaupt noch in irgendeinem, auch in Deutschland irgendwie beliebt?
Nee, oder? Xing ist doch eigentlich komplett...
...bein Arsch, oder?
Also ich bin weder bei LinkedIn noch bei Xing, ich kann da nicht mitreden, das müsst ihr mir sagen
Die Chatgeist-Social-Media-Profi, was das angeht
Also ich glaube, in Deutschland war Xing mal beliebt, aber jetzt auch nicht mehr
Echt? Wirklich?
Ist wirklich Xing immer noch?
Ja, LinkedIn ist das Ding schlechthin
LinkedIn ist doch auch das, wo die ganzen Möchtegern, Elon Musks, ihre Blog-Einträge posten
Was für krasse, krasse Sigma-Mail-Manager sie sind
Bald mit Physie-Ausbildung fertig
Dann geht's endlich in die interne weg aus der...
Ja, nice
Das ist gut, dass du direkt was gefunden hast nach der Ausbildung
Ja
Genau die
Da hab ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht
Aber ja, das gibt's ja auch
So, dann lass uns mal hier fertig gucken
Also, das finde ich, sieht alles richtig gut passend zu dem Titel aus
Ja, es ist jetzt nix drin, wo ich sagen würde, Alter, die suchen eine ganze IT-Abteilung oder was hat das damit zu tun?
Passt wunderbar
Skills
Du hast ein Studium oder Ausbildung schwer...
Okay, übliche Geschichte
Dein Know-How im Umgang mit Linux
Moment, Moment, ich kann nicht mehr lesen richtig, ja
Daniel Lull, Dankeschön, 52 Monate
Massive Subscription, Dankeschön, ja
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice
Excellent, 52 Monate
Deine Gehaltseinstellung
Branche, Region, keine Ahnung
Muss ich erstmal, muss ich mir mal überlegen
Virtualisierung, Netzwerk, Bestandteile wie Firewalls, Router und Switcher sind für dich keine Fremdwörter?
Oh, okay
Ich meine, man muss sagen, das ist schon relativ...
Weit gefasst
Letztendlich
Linux, ja, okay, wunderbar
Aber Firewall, Router, Switcher, Virtualisierung, Linux
Das ist zwar oftmals so im Linux-Umfeld
Aber mit Linux direkt hat es wenig zu tun
Und das sind, wenn man es mal streng nimmt, ist jedes davon ein eigenes Feld, ja
Als Linux-Admin hast du das eine
Als VMware-Admin das andere
Oder als Netzwerk-Admin das andere
Also, aber wenn der Laden nicht so groß ist
Oder, sagen wir mal, die Aufgabengebiete so ein bisschen ineinander übergehen
Ist es natürlich immer nicht verkehrt, ein bisschen was vom anderen auch noch zu verstehen
Erste Berührungspunkte mit Automatisierungstools wie Ansible sind ein großes Plus
Ja, verständlich
Also ich denke, heutzutage, wenn sich einer als Linux-Admin oder generell als...
Muss ja nicht mehr Admin sein
Ja, also im IT-Bereich bewirbt
Und gerade wenn es in Richtung Linux und Cloud
Linux in der Cloud geht oder auch...
Linux im eigenen Rechenzentrum oder On-Prem
Wie das ja heutzutage alle coolen Leute nennen
Dann kann man eigentlich erwarten, dass die Leute ein bisschen Ahnung von Automatisierungstools haben
Und Ansible ist wahrscheinlich das Verbreitetste
Wo du die meisten Leute für findest
Also finde ich nicht verkehrt, das reinzuschreiben
Früher war Puppet angesagt
Weiß nicht, jemand von euch mal ein bisschen was mit Puppet gemacht?
Finde ich...
Ich persönlich finde Puppet gar nicht so übel
Hat ein paar coole Sachen, die Ansible nicht hat
Dafür ist Ansible insgesamt deutlich...
Angenehmer zu schreiben, finde ich
Ich habe früher auch mal schon Sachen noch mit CF-Engine gemacht
Falls mal einer die Ehre hatte, mit CF-Engine was zu machen
Aber Ansible ist, was Serverkonfiguration angeht, eigentlich so...
Sagen wir mal...
Ziemlich Standard
In der Cloud ist es meistens, wenn man es ordentlich macht
Eher so, dass man Ansible gar nicht braucht
Da geht es eher ums Infrastruktur-Professionieren
Und dann ist es meistens Terraform
Gibt sowas wie Pulumi, gibt es auch noch
Aber meistens ist es Terraform und dann ist es Pulumi
Und dann ist es Terraform
Und die Systeme sind da so weit quasi self-contained, dass man meistens kein Ansible mehr braucht
Aber das geht voll klar
Oh, das ist richtig...
Das stelle ich mir eklig vor zusammen
Mann als Loot, was macht man im Alltag mit Ansible?
Okay, Beispiel
Ja, Beispiel
So ganz...
Cloud und so alles außen vor
So mal ganz klassische Sache
Stell dir mal vor
Du betreibst...
Irgendeinen Online-Shop, okay?
Und der Online-Shop besteht aus...
Ein paar Datenbank-Servern
Ein paar Backend-Servern
Ein paar Web-Servern, die das HTML-Zeug ausliefert
Also du hast quasi so eine Umgebung für deinen Web-Shop
Besteht, sagen wir mal so, aus 30 Linux-Servern
Ja, ungefähr
Alles dabei
Frontend, Datenbank, Analyse-Tools und sonst was in der Richtung
Sagen wir mal 30, 30 Server
So, und jetzt hast du das Problem
Du hast das Problem, dass du...
Dir geht einer der Server kaputt
Und die musst du neu aufbauen
Es kann ja auch mal eine VM
Es kann ja...
Es muss ja nicht immer Hardware sein, die ausfällt
Und jetzt willst du diesen Server neu aufbauen
Wie hast du das früher gemacht?
Früher bist du dann hingegangen
Hast dir einen ISO...
Hast dir eine VM angelegt
Hast den ISO reingemountet
Hast das von dem ISO das Betriebssystem installiert
Und dann nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen
Den Server so konfiguriert von Hand
Dass er das macht
Was er machen soll
Du hast den NGINX draufgehauen
Du hast den Postgres draufgehauen
Du hast PAP vielleicht auch früher draufgehauen
Du hast deine Anwendung draufgeschoben
Was auch immer
Und dann stellst du irgendwann fest
Oh Mist
Es gibt immer mal wieder Fehler
Auf dieser Kiste
Weil, ja, vielleicht hast du vergessen
Dass die Verzeichnisberechtigung
Unter Wahl
BWW
Irgendwie anders sein müssen
Und dann hast du dann
Und dann hast du ein paar User
Die konnten den Webshop nicht richtig benutzen
Und haben vielleicht den Bestellvorgang abgebrochen
Weil dein Server halt nicht richtig funktioniert hat
Das ist doof
Hat vielleicht irgendwie 5.000, 6.000 Euro jetzt gekostet
Dass sie das nicht durchführen konnten
Und wenn du sowas wie Ansible benutzt
Dann kannst du diesen Server aufbauen
Lässt Ansible laufen
Und der Server ist exakt in der Konfiguration
Wie du das haben willst
Also wenn du das ganze containerisiert machst
Kommt drauf an
In welchem Umfang
Also wenn
Also ganz im Ernst
Wenn du auf
Also wenn deine Produktionskisten
Hauptsächlich
Auf Container-Workloads
Basieren
Dann würde ich mir tatsächlich mal über ein Kubernetes
Gedanken machen
Weil das ist da wie gemacht dafür
Wobei ich sagen würde
Ich würde Kubernetes nur
Beschränkt empfehlen
Zum Selbstinstallieren und komplett selbst administrieren
Du kannst aber glaube ich auch
Docker Compose
Im Ansible machen
Wobei ganz ehrlich
Das
Kannst du machen
Ist vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll
Du würdest dann aber in Ansible zum Beispiel
So Sachen reinschreiben
Wie
Du legst
Zwei, drei User auf der Kiste an
Du machst einen
Upt-Install-Docker
Einen Upt-Install-Docker-Compose
Du guckst, dass alle SSH-Keys
Von den ganzen Admins verteilt sind
Es gibt ja sehr viele Sachen
An die man vielleicht gar nicht so direkt denkt
Die aber gemacht werden müssen
Nachdem man neuerstens so eine Kiste hat
Nachdem ein neuer Server installiert wird
Dass der überhaupt am Ende so funktionieren kann
Wie er funktionieren soll
Also Ansible ist zum Server konfigurieren
Du baust das System auf
Damit hat Ansible nichts zu tun
Und dann lässt du Ansible laufen
Und Ansible bringt den Server in die Konfiguration
Wie er sein soll
Man kann das beliebig komplexer machen
Ja, es gibt bestimmt auch die Möglichkeit
Dass du so Dinger machst wie
Automatisch ins Loadbalancing aufnehmen
Und sowas mit Ansible
Wobei ich das irgendwie mit
Service-Discovery machen würde
Auf dem Loadbalancer und nicht direkt
Dass Ansible da irgendwas am Loadbalancer dreht
Ja, gibt's jede Menge
Im Cloud-Umfeld ist Ansible
Nicht mehr so angesagt
Weil dort die meisten Kisten
Quasi mit dem Aufbauen fertig sind
In der Cloud werden es eh immer
Zunehmend weniger VMs
Aber oftmals macht man's
Da so, dass man's möglichst
Kleinteilig aufbaut und
Dass die Dinger nach dem Professionieren
Einfach funktionieren
Du lässt vielleicht noch ein Cloud-Init
Laufen auf deiner VM und das ist gut
Wenn du Cloud-Server hast
Wo du viel konfigurieren musst
Extra User unter Linux anlegen
Verzeichnisse anlegen, Dateiberechtigungen
Eigene Mountpoints
Irgendwelche Custom-Pakete drauf und so
Dann kannst du auch im Cloud-Init Ansible
Laufen lassen
Dann hast du ein Terraform
Zum Professionieren deiner VM-Infrastruktur
In der Cloud
Der Ansible ausführt
Und Ansible konfiguriert die Kiste
Das ist
Bisschen umständlich
Es ist immer gut
Wenn die Kisten so
Self-contained aufgebaut werden
Dass man nicht viel konfigurieren muss
Kann man so einfacher
Wegschmeißen
Jetzt hab ich ein bisschen sidetracken lassen
Wir sind immer noch hier dabei
Bis jetzt passt das eigentlich ziemlich gut
Du gehst lösungsorientiert und flexibel
Mit neuen Techniken heraus
Ja passt so
Modern ausgestatteter Arbeitsplatz
Flexible Arbeitszeiten
Flexible Homeoffice Option
Das wird mich ja tatsächlich
Das einzige wo das Icon nicht die richtige Farbe hat
Da hat der CSS
Der CSS-Mann gefailt
Oder
Oder mein Darkreader hat gefailt
Die zwei Varianten gibt es natürlich
Was ihr habt gesagt
Hier gibt es auch einen Obstkorb
Ne gibt es nicht
Was ja mittlerweile eher positiv zu werten ist
Formen kenne ich
Formen haben wir auch eine Weile benutzt
Beim alten Arbeitgeber
Fand ich aber nie so geil ehrlich gesagt
Ist natürlich gut
Kannste PXE-Boot machen
Betriebsthemen installieren
Aber irgendwie bin ich mit Formen nie so richtig warm geworden
Jo
Also ich finde das ist nicht schlecht
Das ist jetzt vielleicht keine Stellanzeige
Wo ich sagen würde
Oh ja die sprüht vor
Innovation
Also nicht unbedingt von der Stelle
Super innovativ geschrieben
Oder so
Aber passt zu der Beschreibung
Und vom Inhalt her würde ich sagen
Passt das auch gut
Zum Gehaltsforderung Leute
Ich kann euch dazu nichts sagen
Es ist nicht so als wäre ich irgendwie krasser Personalvermittlungsdude
Der deutschlandweit
Erfahrung hat oder sowas
Ich kann euch
Wenn überhaupt was sagen
Was Frankfurter Versicherungen und Bankenumfeld angeht
Und
Frankfurter Finanzbranche ein bisschen
Aber ansonsten
Wir hatten es doch letztens mal
Davon als Einstiegsgehalt
Wir hatten doch letztens mal
Mein Einstiegsgehalt hochgerechnet
30 bis 35k
Nach Ausbildung ist viel zu wenig
Nach Ausbildung hatte ich ja schon
Und das ist über 10 Jahre her
Wir hatten letztens mal mein Einstiegs
Mein Einstiegsgehalt
Ich glaube beim Spiegel hatten wir das irgendwie oder
Wo war das dann Spiegel?
Konzentrationsrechner hatten wir doch hier
Hier
Bruttogehalt 33.500
2007 bis jetzt 46k
Also ich finde 46k
Ist nach der Ausbildung gute
War auch in Frankfurt
Ist denke ich ein gutes Einstiegsgehalt
Ich denke
Da kann man mal anpeilen
Also habe ich jetzt
Hochgerechnet aus meinem Einstiegsgehalt
Kommt sicherlich
Extrem auf die Region an
Das wird in Frankfurt mehr
Sein als irgendwie
Im Osten auf dem Land
Oder so
Vermutlich, vielleicht haben die da auch so IT-Mangel
Das es da mehr ist, kann man immer schlecht sagen
Es ist auf jeden Fall sehr abhängig von Region
Und auch ein bisschen von der Branche
Man muss halt sagen Versicherung und Banken
Und gerade in Frankfurt bezahlen halt
Gibt es ja auch Statistik drüber
Bezahlen dann wirklich echt nicht schlecht
Ich glaube gefolgt von
Pharmaindustrie
Gefolgt von Automobilindustrie
Wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe
Zertifikate bringen nichts
Also meiner Ansicht nach
Ich würde da auch nichts drauf geben
Wenn einer ein Kubernetes Zertifikat hat
Also ich würde
Im Vorstellungsgespräch
Nicht fragen
Haben sie ein Kubernetes Zertifikat
Wenn einer
Waren die Stellen die wir sind gerade dabei
Wenn einer sagt Kubernetes Erfahrung
Dann würde ich den irgendwas praktisches
Fragen so
Keine Ahnung
Wie stellst du
Die
Wie lässt du dem Ingress
Eine neue externe IP zuweisen
Zum Beispiel
Sowas in der Richtung
Irgendwas wo man halt merkt
Okay der hat ein bisschen Ahnung davon
Was er macht
Der Config File bringt dir in dem Fall
So beschränkt was
Also du musst halt wissen
Was du da reinschreibst
Oder was du mit kubectl machst
Und ein paar Stichwörter würde ich dann schon hören
Also 45%
Musst du doch erstmal hinkriegen
Dann
Du bist ja hier anonym
Dann erhelle uns doch mal
Ich nehme ja immer meine Sachen
Als Vergleich wenn mich einer was fragt
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt
Wenn wir ein bisschen mehr Vergleich haben
Dann erhelle uns doch mal
Sanjo welche Branche
Beziehungsweise welche Region
Wenn du die Branche nicht sagen willst
Und was hast du vorgekriegt und was kriegst du jetzt
Und und
Also auch das Tätigkeits
Tätigkeitsbereich
Wenn du die exakte Stellenbezeichnung nicht sagen willst
Umso mehr Vergleichsachen wir haben
Umso besser
Das glaube ich nicht dass Zertifikate viel bringen
Ich kenne keine auf Zertifikate guckt
Vielleicht
Vielleicht wenn du dich beim Amt bewirbst
Haben die das nach Region
Aufgesplittet
Ansonsten bringt dir der bundesweite Durchschnitt
Für deine Sachen nicht sonderlich viel
Wie lange haben bei dir
Die Rückmeldung auf deine Bewerbung gebraucht
Ähm
Sehr schnell
Also ich habe in meinem Leben nicht viele Bewerbungen geschrieben
Es ist nicht so als hätte ich da jetzt
Krasse Erfahrung
Für die Ausbildungsstelle
Habe ich glaube ich
Zwei Bewerbungen oder so geschrieben
Und
Weiß ich gar nicht ob ich von den einen was gehört habe
Die anderen
Haben sich relativ schnell gemeldet
Und nach Vorstellungsgespräch haben sie mich einen Tag später angerufen
Und haben gesagt ja wollen sie
Und jetzt beim letzten
Beim letzten
Musste ich ja gar nicht mal richtig Bewerbungen
Schreiben
Da wurde ich ja angerufen
Also
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen
Mir fehlen die Stichproben dafür
Ne Studiumssachen kann ich dir
Nichts helfen
Ja okay dann
Würde ich mal sagen
Das haben wir
Dann next
IT Admin Mac OS
Das ist mal was besonderes
Das sieht man selten
Windows Admins in Massen
Linux auch in Massen
Aber Mac
Mac noch nicht
Das ist doch bestimmt
Irgendeine
Marketing Agentur oder sowas
Wenn die Mac OS Leute
Suchen was ist das
Man kann es ja kaum lesen
Es liegt aber bestimmt an meinem
Ne das kann man okay das kann man das kann also
Das ist ne wirklich schlechte Wahl
Der Schriftfarbe
Auf dem Hintergrund
Let's build the amazing
The incredible
The impossible
Alter jetzt ist ja mal gut
Kriegt euch ab
One global team
A world of opportunities
A world of friends from
What the
Ach du
Keine Ahnung was bei denen abgeht
Aber
So also was gibts denn hier schönes
Admin Mac OS
Für unseren Standort in Hamburg
Mit circa 130 Mitarbeiter
Suchen wir deinen Support als
IT System Administrator
All Genders
Du kümmerst dich um
Die Geräte überwiegend Mac Books
Und okay das finde ich schon mal
Cool besser als den Windows
Mist mit dem ich mich
Darum schlage also ich bin kein Windows Admin
Ich benutze den Kram nur
Aber besser als mit den Windows Mist
Mit dem ich mich da rumschlagen muss
Und leiste Support für unsere Mitarbeiter
Sorgst aber auch dafür das unser modernes Office
Über den Dächern Hamburgs stets gut und sicher
Sag mal wie viele Dächer
Hat Hamburg eigentlich
Gefühlt in jeder zweiten Stellenanzeige
Wo was von Hamburg steht steht
Über den Dächern Hamburgs
Haben die irgendwie da so ne
So nen Kletterwald
Oder wo die alle sind
Die Website hat kein Impressum
Das wirkt doch schon
Naja gut das hier ist glaube ich
Keine Ahnung was das ist
Impressum ist outdated
DSGVO Abmahnung ist raus
Ach du meinst wegen Überschwemmungen
In Hamburg sind die alle auf dem Dach
Ja gut
GipLab benutzen die
Alles klar easy
GipLab
Da hat ja der Experte
Geschrieben wieder
Okay neue Kollegen
Begleitest du im Onboarding
Durch die Bestellung der Hardware
Und die Einrichtung aller notwendigen Accounts
Blablabla
Kümmerst dich um die Arbeitsplätze unserer Mitarbeiter
Und stellst auch entsprechende Tische bereit
What
Du stellst auch entsprechende Tische bereit
Ich geh in den Keller
Und trag den Tisch hoch
Ja gut
Da hätte ich jetzt persönlich keinen Bock drauf
Aber wenn sie es ordentlich bezahlen
Trage ich denen auch einen Tisch
Du unterstützt bei Verwaltung
Der Mitarbeiter Accounts unter anderem
Google Slack
Opera
Confluence
GipLab
Genauso gehört die Verwaltung der Softwarelizenzen
Zu deinem Aufgabenbereich
Okay das ist super vage
Die Verwaltung der Softwarelizenzen
Ist wahrscheinlich auf
Serials Punkt
Ich sag es jetzt nicht zu gehen
Und sich was rauszusuchen
Das kann ich dir ganz einfach beantworten
Guck dir doch auf Youtube
Falls du noch nicht gesehen hast
Das Video an was ich aktuell verdiene
Da hätte ich keinen Bock was neues zu machen
Ich hätte allgemein keinen Bock
Was neues zu machen zur Zeit
Es sei denn es ist wirklich irgendwas
Was ich mir jetzt nicht ausmalen kann
Und so geil finde
Und vielleicht noch besser bezahlt
Das ich nicht widerstehen könnte
Aber das sieht aktuell nicht so aus
Also sagen wir mal so
Unter 110k im Jahr möchte ich
Also für 5 Tage gerechnet
Kannst dann runterrechnen auf meine 4 Tage
Würde ich das
Würde ich mir das nicht überlegen
Also es muss eher noch eine Ecke mehr sein
Dass ich es mir überhaupt überlege
Zumal dann bei mir noch der Bonus dabei kommt
Also
Da müsste schon ordentlich
Was rumkommen
Ich sag mal für 150k
Und eine super Stelle würde ich es mir überlegen
Aber ich habe keine
Wechselinteressen aktuell
Aber man soll ja nie nie sagen
Man weiß ja nicht was da noch kommt
Ah hier
Es ist interessant
Wegen den 45% Mehrgehalt aktuell
IT Systemkaufmann
IHK Ausbildung
Das ist ja nicht schlecht
Du bist ja quasi erst
Naja fast fertig
Seit 4 Jahren fertig
Finanzbranche Düsseldorf
41k IT DevOps
Bisher gewesen oder
Und dann bist du ab 1.1.
65k in Köln Versicherungssoftware
Ja das ist natürlich ein ganz guter Sprung
Wobei man auch wirklich sagen muss 41k
Für einen DevOps Engineer ist halt echt schon
Bisschen sehr knauserig
Ja und ich denke
Mit dem Gehalt hast du gute Chancen
Die nächsten Jahre nochmal
Einen ganz ganz guten Sprung zu machen
Wenn du was drauf hast
Und
Das sagen wir mal
Wenigstens semi gut verkaufen kannst
Wie gesagt es ist ja immer mindestens
Genauso wichtig
So viel Zeit reinzustecken über das zu reden
Was man tolles gemacht hat
Wie tolle Sachen zu machen
Und dann
Gibt es Stonks
Die nächsten Jahre über
Geht es nach oben
Hä verstehe ich nicht
Was ich bin alt
Ja ich bin alt
Ich habe keine NDA
Was willst du denn wissen
Ich verstehe es nicht
Ja ja jetzt Leute
Lasst euch von dem was
Das ist das gleiche wie auf Reddit
Ihr müsst mal Reddit
Subreddit Arbeitsleben gucken
Da ist jedes zweite Kommentar
Sofort kündigen
Dem Chef auf den Tisch kacken
Und neuen Job suchen
Oder so unter 80k
Stehe ich gar nicht mehr auf
Lasst euch von irgendwelchem
Gelaber im Internet nicht ganz so sehr
Beeinflussen
Ja ist halt
Ist halt so
Wie gesagt es kommt enorm
Auf die Branche und
Die Region an
Ich würde es gerne beantworten
Aber du musst mir erklären was du meinst
Also ich meine wenn du sagst
Ich will 110k plus
Ich stehe dann vor dir der dich anstellt
Was wie würdest du argumentieren
Gar nicht
Ich würde es einfach nicht in Erwägung ziehen
Wenn ich weniger bekomme
Ganz einfach
Ich würde gar nicht vor dir stehen
Wenn du weniger bietest
Weil ich keinerlei Interesse habe zu wechseln
Und dann schon irgendwas super krasses
Kommen muss
Mit 4 Jahren Erfahrung ist das
Durchaus noch im okayen Bereich
Wobei ich denke
So wenn wir mal sagen
Einstiegsgehalt von 45k
Wie gesagt ich kann es immer nur von meinem
Einstiegsgehalt ausgehen
Hochgerechnet auf die aktuelle Zeit
Ist nach 4 Jahren 55k
Jetzt vielleicht
Also auch 100%
Vielleicht so eher am unteren
Ende
Also du hast auf jeden Fall
Chancen das noch ordentlich zu steigern
Die nächsten Jahre über
Ob es beim aktuellen
Ups da wollte ich jetzt gar nicht
Ob es natürlich bei deinem Arbeitgeber geht
Das kann ich jetzt auch nicht wissen
5 nx
Wie findest du Jobs im Securitybereich
Jo
Wann was
Das ist so wie
Wie findest du Jobs
Im
Automobilbereich
Das kann ja alles sein
Kann ich nicht aussprechen hab Dankeschön für den Sub
5 nx danke für den Sub
Also ich okay
Ich versuche mal trotzdem was gescheites dazu zu sagen
Also mal angenommen
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Hätte ich jetzt keinen Job
Gehen wir mal davon aus
Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen hätte ich keinen Job
Und
Ich würde mich irgendwo bewerben
Und wir hätten ein Vorstellungsgespräch
Und ich würde da sitzen
Und irgendwie würde mich
Du würdest mich fragen wie viel wollen sie haben
So meinst du das oder
Ja dann würde ich tatsächlich auch
110k oder 105k
Wahrscheinlich würde ich 110k sagen
Allein schon aus dem Grund
Weil
Du musst ja
Irgendwas du musst ja irgendwie meine Hausnummer sagen
Und nachdem es eigentlich
Immer weniger ist als das was du gesagt hast
Kann das ruhig erstmal ein bisschen zu viel sein
Und wie ich das dann argumentieren würde ist
Naja es kommt auf die
Stellenanzeige an ich mein
Je nachdem wie gut
Und nicht gut das passt ich mein
Ich mach den Kram seit 15 Jahren
Ich kenne mich in den und den Bereichen
Super aus wofür sie mich brauchen
Kommt
Das kommt auf die Situation an
Ich glaube nicht das es eine universelle
Keine Ahnung
Vorstellungsgespräch
Argumentation gibt
Wo man immer exakt sein Wunschgehalt bekommt
Ja geht ja noch weiter
Du kannst ja noch Architekt werden falls
So was gibt bei euch
Hi Fun Dankeschön für den Sub
Stand jetzt welche Ausbildung
Wolltest du heute machen
Wahrscheinlich wieder die gleiche
So jetzt sollen wir mal weiter machen hier
Wo bin ich denn hier gelandet
Was das bist du
Wobei wir waren mit der anderen noch gar nicht
Fertig oder
Also der MacOS Admin
Du bist mitverhandelt
Du bist mitverhandelt für die internen Netze
Am Standort Wlan VPN
Switche Firewall
Neben unseren Videokonferenzsystemen
Wird noch die Telefon
Alter jetzt ist ja mal gut
Ey
Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber
Ey man also komm
Jetzt ist ja irgendwann mal gut
Die wollen
Die wollen das du
Ok du bist IT Admin
Du bist IT System Administrator
Für ok MacOS
Du sollst jetzt
Du sollst die Leute on und off boarden
Mit den Geräten
Das verstehe ich irgendwie noch
Die Inventarisierung und sonst was
Und Hardware Bestellung ist eigentlich nicht deine Aufgabe
Aber lass ich mir in einem kleinen Laden
Irgendwie noch ein bisschen gefallen ok
Ähm
Dass ich seriously Tische tragen muss
Kann man vielleicht
Auch noch irgendwie machen
Wenn man da keine Probleme
Ich hätte da zum Beispiel keinen Bock
So dann kümmerst du dich um die Softwareverwaltung
Äh kümmerst dich um das Accountmanagement
Für den ganzen Campbell
Oder auch für GipLab
Äh dann kümmerst du dich um Netzwerkverwaltung
Um ihr WLAN
Um ihr VPN Zeug
Um ihre Switch Firewalls
ETC gibt wahrscheinlich noch mehr
Und die Fritzbox wahrscheinlich auch
Vielleicht haben die noch noch Fritzbox irgendwo stehen
Dann sollst du noch nebenbei
Videokonferenzsysteme machen
Telefonanlage
Und dann auch noch die fucking Drucker und Scanner
Jetzt ist ja irgendwann mal gut
Und dann sollst du Enduser Support machen
Ne
Also das ist bescheuert
Wird noch besser kann er fast noch nicht besser werden
Ist das ne
Gbait Anzeige oder was
Neben der technischen Betreuung
Kümmerst du dich auch um zum Beispiel
Verkabelung im Office an
Das ist doch ein Witz
Das ist doch ein Witz oder
Ok Leute ich weiß
Ich weiß was das ist
Ohne Gbait
Ich scroll jetzt runter gleich
Und unten drunter steht sinngemäß
Einfach nur den besten
Oder sowas
Ja also
Das wird bestimmt jetzt immer abgedrehter
Und am Ende steht
Wir haben dich nur verarscht aber wir suchen dich trotzdem
Anders kann ich mir das langsam nicht mehr erklären
Ok
Wir tun mal so als wäre es ernst
Neben der technischen Betreuung
Kümmerst du dich auch um zum Beispiel
Verkabelung im Office anbringen
Ach Fernsehen
Ich hab Fenster gelesen ich hab Fenster gelesen aber
Die kann ich jetzt einfach immer noch
Verkabelung und Kümmerst du dich auch um
Oder den austausch von Glühbirnen
Und sorgst dafür das unser Office nicht nur
Technisch gut ausge...
What the fuck
Alter was ist mit denen los
Das ist so schlecht
Falls ihr das mal echt ernst macht
Das muss ich mir mal speichern
Glühbirnen Wechseln
Verkabelung
Vieles davon darfst du als
Random IT Dude
Gar nicht verkabeln
eine abgeschlossene Ausbildung im IT-Bereich.
Ja, okay.
Erste Erfahrung mit
Administration, Betreuung von IT...
Achso, ja, erste Erfahrungen reichten
sicherlich aus, um die komplette IT-Abteilung
alleine zu geben. Ja, gar kein Problem.
Genau.
Du bist Elektriker,
Administrator und Hausmeister.
Und Umzugshelfer.
Vielleicht...
Ich meine, man könnte
sicherlich auch mal neu streichen, oder?
So ein bisschen Farbe an die Wand ab und zu,
wenn es nicht mal agile genug ist, das Büro.
Wenn es nicht mal diagonal
skaliert, dann muss man eine andere Farbe hin.
Erste Erfahrung mit der Administration...
Okay, du besitzt Kenntnisse, Erfahrungen mit Mac, MacOS
und unserer Tool-Landschaft.
Google Suite, Slack, Jira,
Confluent... Ach, hier ist ein GitLab, okay.
Vielleicht, genau,
vielleicht sind die Clos auch mal verstopft zwischendurch.
Du bist...
Warum bin ich eine Ganzzahl?
Und hast ein
ausgeprägtes Sicherheitsverständnis, okay.
Du schreckst
vor handwerklichen Tätigkeiten
nicht zurück.
Also, da muss ich sagen, ich schrecke tatsächlich
vor handwerklichen Tätigkeiten nicht zurück.
Ich mache ziemlich viel bei mir daheim. Ich bastle auch
unglaublich gerne und seit ich mein Fahrrad
habe, bin ich auch öfters am Fahrrad schrauben, obwohl
ich davon keinen Plan habe und lerne das
auch gerne und sowas, aber
nicht in meinem
Job.
Selbst da würde ich es machen, aber es ist halt nicht
mein Job, das zu machen.
Also, ich würde gerne ab und zu noch mal
im Rechenzentrum ein paar Server schrauben.
Hätte ich gar kein Problem mit, ja.
Aber Glühbirnen wechseln vielleicht dann doch nicht.
Nice, du bist
Fachkraft für Arbeitssicherheit, für die
sicherheitstechnische Betreuung. Ah, auch noch, okay.
Gute kommunikative
Fähigkeit. In Deutsch
und Englisch runden dein Profil ab. Wir bieten dir
einen Job in vollzeitter Teil. Du entscheidest.
Wenn du willst, Einstieg in die
FFW-Band.
Die verarschen uns doch, oder?
Quereinsteiger
sind willkommen. FFW wird
klimaneutral mit Agencies for Future.
Ja.
Das reißt jetzt auch noch mehr raus.
Hybrides Arbeitmodell.
Kombi aus Remote und Office mit Fleck.
Wird schwierig, aus dem Homeoffice die Glühbirne
zu wechseln.
Wöchentliches gemeinsames Frühstück und
Lunchlotterie. Oh, das klingt
nach gezwungenen sozialen
Events.
Ein offener Zuschuss für ÖPNV.
Ah, die gibt noch nicht mal ein Ticket. Okay.
Ich weiß
ja nicht, Leute.
Lunchlotterie ist,
dass man random Leute zu Mittag schickt.
Ach, ist das so ein
Heute-treffen-sich-random-Leute-bei-Mittag?
Oh, nee. Das ist so krass gezwungen.
Da hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock. Gibt's bei mir auf der Arbeit
auch. Ich hab mal ganz kurz
überlegt, ganz am Anfang, als ich neu war,
ob ich das mir nicht einmal
angucken soll, weil man
Es ist immer doof, über was abzulästern,
was man noch gar nicht ausprobiert hat. Aber ich hab
es da nicht gemacht, weil ich finde sowas immer richtig
ätzend.
Also, wir haben bei uns auf der Arbeit auch sowas.
Da heißt es nicht Lunchlotterie, sondern
ich glaube Mittagessen-Speed-Dating
heißt es dort oder so. So in der Richtung
heißt es, glaube ich. Mittagessen-Speed-Dating.
Aber habe ich mich nie dazu angemeldet.
Ey, ey.
Wir mussten mal, wenn du das gerade
erzählst, wir mussten mal
ein Playcenter einbauen, relativ weit
oben im Rack.
Zu zweit, glücklicherweise. Das war
auch ein Akt. Die Dinger sind übelst schwer.
8 HE groß.
Ich meine, aber seriously,
ich meine, da kannst du dir echt wehtun bei,
ja. Da hättet ihr auch mal
einen rüberschicken können und sagen, hier,
ähm, pass mal auf, dass das nicht auf den Fuß fällt.
Weil aus der Höhe, wenn
dir die Kiste auf den Fuß fällt,
da ist der Fuß im Arsch.
Aber die hatte bestimmt Sicherheitsschuhe an, oder?
Niemand im Rechenten
holt Sicherheitsschuhe an, Leute.
Habt ihr,
ja, serious Frage, Leute.
Von euch, die noch öfters ins Rechenzentrum müssen,
habt ihr Sicherheitsschuhe an?
Niemand hat Sicherheitsschuhe an im Rechenzentrum.
Ich hätte noch nicht mal
gewusst früher, und als ich noch beim Provider
gearbeitet hab, also in der Zeit, ich war,
hab ich euch oft erzählt, es war täglich Stunden
im Rechenzentrum. Ich wusste noch nicht mal
überhaupt, wo wir Sicherheitsschuhe hätten.
Gehabt hätten dafür.
Nee, die musst du nicht tragen.
Aber es wäre oftmals, gerade
wenn man schwere Kisten einbaut,
gar nicht blöd, sowas anzuziehen.
Ich hab's einmal live,
erlebt, da ist ein Kollege
eine 2HE-HP-Kiste
aus der Hand gefallen, so
Höhe vom Tragen, also jetzt nicht irgendwie
aus 3 Meter Höhe auf den Fuß.
Nein, der hat den Server getragen
und ist
ihm aus der Hand gerutscht, und da
so eine vollbeladene 2HE-HP-Kiste
mit Festplatten, wiegt halt auch mal 20
Kilo, die ist ihm so aus Tragehöhe
mit der Kante vom Server, so schön
schräg, ne,
schräge Kante vom Server, auf den Fuß
geklatscht.
Da war er erst mal 2 Wochen weg,
konnte nicht mehr laufen.
Glücklicherweise war der Fuß nicht durch.
Ja, also das kann echt ins Auge, ist
falsche Formulierung, aber ihr wisst, was ich
meine, das kann echt ins Auge gehen.
Also manchmal wäre es nicht verkehrt,
welche anzuziehen, aber niemand zieht sich
Sicherheitsschuhe im Rechenzentrum an.
Ja, Jacken, Jacken, ich würde sagen,
Jacken und Gehörschutz sind eigentlich
Standard bei den meisten.
Ich habe aber gar nichts angezogen, also
ich hatte selten was an, ich hatte noch
nicht mal morgens was angezogen.
Ich habe euch ja erzählt, ich habe
morgens immer Rundgang gemacht durch
mehrere Rechenzentren im
Dunklen, weil es für mich quasi
verlängerte Nachtruhe war.
Ich bin quasi im Halbschlaf auf die
Arbeit gefahren, dann erst mal eineinhalb
Stunden Rechenzentrum-Rundgang im
Dunklen, da konnte ich noch gefühlt
weiter schlafen dabei und ich habe keine
Jacke angezogen und keine Ohrschützer.
Ich finde den Rechenzentrums-Lärm nicht
schlimm.
Es wird erst schlimm,
wenn du es wirklich den ganzen Tag hast.
Also wenn du ganz nachher was einbaust,
dann wird es schon ätzend irgendwann.
Aber meistens muss man dann dort auch
nicht den ganzen Tag im Rechenzentrum
stehen, sondern einbauen, verkabeln und
dann irgendwas konfigurieren.
Ja, Management, Interface, sonst was und
da gibt es ja glücklicherweise meistens
einen eigenen Raum für. Oder man ist ganz
Hardcore und macht es noch mit dem
Rollwagen, wo der Monitor drauf ist.
Das hätte ich auch gerne gehabt, aber bei
uns früher haben die lieber zwei Jahre zu machen.
Da haben sie uns Hubis rüber geschickt ins
Rechenzentrum um 8 HE-Kisten einzubauen.
Wir waren die Server-Heber, aber ich
sage euch, wenn ihr schon mal über
Kopfhöhe ein Playcenter eingebaut habt,
da habt ihr keinen Bock mehr drauf und ich
bin jetzt mit 1,74 nicht der Größte, also
das geht echt auf die Arme.
Mich hast du bestimmt nicht gesehen.
Das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
So Kisten kosten einiges. Wir hatten auch
mal Loadbalancer für die Kiste, aber das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Wir hatten auch mal Loadbalancer für die Kiste, aber das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
So ist das für 50.000 Euro das Stück.
So Appliance Dinger. Normale Linienkisten kosten nicht so viel.
Sollten wir mit so nem komischen Bollerwagen über ne abschüssige Straße mehrere übereinander gestapelt rüberfahren.
So sollten wir mit so nem komischen Bollerwagen über ne abschüssige Straße mehrere übereinander gestapelt rüberfahren.
Das waren Dinger, also die
Stellenanzeige ist komplett bescheuert.
Also keine Ahnung was mit denen los ist.
Ich dachte auch die ist Cheapbait, aber
anscheinend ist sie nicht debate anscheinend ist sie nicht debate ja ich
habe aber nie gesagt ich habe ich habe noch nie bock drauf gab ich habe immer
gesagt will ich nicht ja also gerade mein ganz alter chef damals der hat mir
gefühlt halbjährlich die karrieremöglichkeiten im unternehmen
immer wieder erzählt und sie haben mich ja auch mal kurzzeitig dazu genötigt bei
einem projekt die vertretung vom projektleiter zu machen
das habe ich einmal und nie wieder gemacht ich habe echt kein bock auf so
was es ist die letzte in letzter zeit ist es weniger geworden
beim alten arbeitgeber ist es quasi überhaupt nicht mehr vorgekommen
spätestens als seit ich teilzeit arbeite so gut wie gar nicht mehr weil die sich
gedacht haben okay der max hat keinen bock auf den scheiß ja wir haben es dann
langsam verstanden und beim neuen wurde ich noch nicht
gefragt
aber beim neuen werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht gefragt da
haben wir so ein internes führungskräfte förder ran für programm und da bewerben
sich die leute drauf die bock haben das zu machen und die haben genug bewerber
das heißt die werden mich gar nicht fragen und das ist auch gut so weil ich
würde nicht machen wollen man sollte ja chat ihr habt recht ich
würde echt mal interessieren was die bezahlen also also dafür müssten die
wirklich in enorm ordentlich bezahlen was sie nicht machen am ende bezahlen
sind wahrscheinlich 35k oder so was und sagen dann ja aber bei uns ist doch die
coole familiäre atmosphäre da kann man doch auch mal ein bisschen und so ihr
wisst schon also das bewirb dich doch heute ja
ganz bestimmt so okay glückliche menschen wieder am start leute
glückliche glückliche menschen alle wieder super happy und am lachen weil so eine luhe aussehen könnte wir Noniais nicht gekeiten nirgends.
aufs handy zeigen wie in echt datenbank ingenieur it berater db2z alter jetzt
wird es aber business enterprise keck finanzbranche alter monka stier ich
muss ich muss das mal kurz überfahren sekunde ich wusste meine abneigung da
gerade mal dagegen zum ausdruck bringen ich wollte nicht die kann ich dass mich
jetzt einer falsch übersteht das galt nicht meiner meiner katze hier unten ja
sondern db2 und zos also die haben wohl noch einen ibm mainframe würde ich
sagen okay bla bla bla bla db2 ist wahrscheinlich auch nur sql sowie fast
jede datenbank in irgendeiner art und weise sql kann
wobei ich ehrlich gesagt
ich weiß nicht warum ich das so sagen kann ich weiß nicht warum ich das so sagen kann
gar nicht weiß ob db2 wahrscheinlich können sie das aber zos ist das
betriebssystem von den ganzen ibm mainframe liga die sehen so aus ja genau
so sehen die aus bei manchen sehen ja auch noch so aus aber so so so in dieser
weise sehen die aus ja die sehen immer ein bisschen anders aus jedes mal wenn
ich wenn ich wenn ich mir so ein einzeln sieht ein bisschen anders aus aber im
prinzip sehen die dinger so ähnlich aus
und wisst ihr wisst ihr was das ganz tolle daran ist ibm hat auch ein super
tolles lizenzmodell ihr denkt jetzt vielleicht wenn ihr euch für sehr viel
geld es geht da ab rgb mod wenn ihr euch für sehr viel geld ein ibm mainframe
kauft dann gehört er euch nein das ist nicht so der gehört euch nicht ihr müsst
die rechenleistung darauf nach wie vor bezahlen obwohl ihr den bei euch im
rechenzentrum stehen hat und gekauft habt ihr bezahlt ihr bezahlt quasi pro cpu in dem ding
das nennt sich über mainframes es gibt so ein komisches wort für so einen so einen
rechenslice bei so einem mainframe vergessen wie das heißt und und bei einem
mainframe macht man auch keine reboot sondern bei einem mainframe macht man
einen wie heißt das l paar oder sowas chad kennt sich jemand mit mainframes
aus ipl nicht elper ipl hieß das ding genau ja ich sehe jetzt sagt silva kennt sich aus
Sowas suchen die anscheinend
Ach, Elpa sind die
VMs und IPL ist der
Ja Leute, wie gesagt, ich hab damit nix großartig zu tun
Ich hab die letzten Jahre immer ein bisschen was aufgeschnappt
Ich will das nicht tun als
Ich wollte jetzt nicht die Fachbegriffe droppen
Um zu zeigen, ich bin der krasse Mainframe-Kenner
Ich hab davon überhaupt keine Ahnung
Ein paar Sachen hab ich mitgekriegt, das war's aber auch
Also
Folgende Aufgaben fallen
In ihren
Ach, hier steht's doch, guck, DB2-Datenbank im IBM
ZOS-Umfeld
Architektonische
Und strategische Weiterentwicklung
Unserer DB2-Datenbank
Analyse von
Performance-Engpässen
Und Ableiten von Optimierungsmöglichkeiten
Für Anwendungsentwicklung
Und IT-Betrieb
Ausbau des Monitorings
Im Hinblick auf Analyse und Prognosemöglichkeiten
Des Systems
Aha
Ähm
Und
Erfahrung mit DB2-Datenbank
Sicherer Umgang mit
IBM ZOS-Mainframe
TSO
Das, das, das hab ich
Das kenn ich
Das, das hab ich
Da hab ich schon mal gehört im Mainframe-Umfeld
Rack
Oder Rack-F oder so
Gibt das irgendwie Rack-F-IDs?
Und sowas, das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor
DB2-SQL
Gute Arbeitsweise geprägt von bla bla bla bla bla bla
Übrigens, wir legen von Beginn an Wert auf eine intensive Einarbeit
Ja, das ist gut
Kommt euch ja auch zugute
Ich find's immer geil
Wenn, wenn das
Ich mein, das ist ja schon von Vorteil, ne?
Aber wenn die das so schreiben
Ich finde, das sollte zum
Zum eigensten
Zum ureigensten Interesse gehören
Eines Unternehmens, die neue Leute einstellen
Dass sie die Leute ordentlich einarbeiten
Weil sonst bekommen sie einfach nicht
Nichts richtig für ihr Geld
Erst Berechtigungsmanagement
Ja, ja, das ergibt Sinn
Auch vielfältig
Vielfältige Bildungshintergrund
Wir sind aufgeschlossen gegenüber Talenten
Deren Lebenslauf auf den ersten Blick
Nicht hundertprozentig zu den Anforderungen
Das finde ich gut, dass sie das so schreiben
Ja
Ich mein, man muss sagen
Super ansprechend finde ich die Stellenanzeige
Jetzt trotzdem nicht
Also unabhängig davon, dass ich absolut keinen Bock
Auf DB2-ZOS hätte
Aber super ansprechend finde ich
Finde ich nicht
Also seriously
Die vier hier
Die sind deutlich zu jung
Um ZOS-Admins zu sein
Also erstmal in der IT-Abteilung
Das Verhältnis
Ein Kerl auf drei Mädels
Ist sehr unrealistisch
Wenn auch nice, aber unrealistisch
Und die sind allesamt
Viel zu jung
Um DB2-ZOS zu machen
Mehr Details zu unseren Benefits
Kulinarik
Wie sieht es mit Homeoffice aus?
Hybrides Arbeiten
Spiel mal den Film ab
Man meinte der ist cringe
Super agil mit Basketball
Bei einem Asset Manager ermöglichst du Träume
Sorgst mit Voraussicht für...
Ey, so typischer Business Enterprise Film!
Du bist
Naja
Das war so ein typischer Promotion Film halt
Den hätte man eigentlich auch weglassen können ja
Ja, mich würde es auch eher abschrecken
Die skalieren bestimmt auch diagonal
Ah
Was haben wir hier noch?
Wir hatten doch noch mehr
Jetzt!
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt drauf, Mann.
Was ist das hier?
Das Bistrum Trier
ist wieder am Start.
Ne, was heißt wieder?
Ist am Start.
Das Bistrum...
Bistum? Nicht Bistrum.
Bistum Trier.
Alter, was ein Wort.
Also Jobs, weiß ich nicht.
Hab ich nicht geguckt. Wir haben auch nur
Chat-Kontributete
Stellenanzeigen bis jetzt.
Bistum.
Nicht Bistum.
Was?
Bistum.
Wir klauen an dich.
Ja gut, ich mein, klauen musst du da.
Brake machen
die wahrscheinlich den ganzen Tag.
Mal kurz was trinken, Leute.
Vor dieser Stellenanzeige
muss ich ne Runde beten. Sekunde.
Jesus, ja.
Als Beistand.
So, erst mal
was getrunken.
Also, weiter.
Da werden erst mal die Racks
mit Weihwasser, ja.
Für stabileren Betrieb.
Hey, Leute.
Beten vor OS-Upgrades ist nie verkehrt.
Es bringt zwar
wahrscheinlich nix,
aber manche Leute beruhigt das.
Wir haben hier im Chat, ohne Mist,
ich glaube, wir haben hier einen enorm
hohen Skill-Level.
Was IT-Sachen angeht im Chat.
Hier sind schon einige Five-Header am Start.
Merke ich immer wieder, weil wir machen
ja hier im Stream auch die unterschiedlichsten Sachen.
Ja, von Micro-Controller
bis Web-Frontend, Backend
und sonst was. Und da sind
nicht alle, ja, es gibt so Leute wie
der Chainlord zum Beispiel oder sowas.
Aber es gibt,
sogar der Chainlord hat manchmal Five-Head-Momente.
Kommt manchmal vor.
Sind schon wirklich schlaue Leute
am Start hier. Sehe ich immer wieder.
Ja.
Was?
Was denn ein Five-Header ist?
Jemand, der so schlau ist, dass sein Kopf
so aussieht. Guck.
Das ist ein Five-Header.
Der hat so viel
Gehirn, dass es nicht mehr richtig reinpasst.
Viele, viele. Aber nicht
alle. Wir haben letztens mal,
hatten wir sogar eine Umfrage.
Okay, dann schauen wir uns das jetzt mal an,
was das Bistum
Trier
so haben will. Arbeit im,
ich sag weiter Bistum, ich kann das sonst nicht aussprechen.
Das siehst du falsch.
Wir sind alle Three-Head in 90% der Sachen.
Aber wir sind Five-Head in vielleicht ein paar einzelnen Sachen.
Niemand ist Five-Head immer und überall.
Wir sind eigentlich in den meisten Themen Three-Head.
Aber in manchen ist man, ist man eben.
Naja, zumindest Four-Head, ja.
Laut Duden ist deine Aussprache korrekt.
Siehst du? Three-Head-Moment vom Chat wieder.
Aber mein Chat kennt sich auch mit ZOS und DBZ.
ZB2 aus.
Ist mit Aussprache und sowas natürlich kann man nicht so viel erwarten.
Also, ne Moment.
Ja, also was wollen sie denn haben?
Mitwirkung einer Digitalisierung Strategie des Bistums Triers inklusive der Weiterentwicklung.
Okay, da passt der Standard 0815 bla bla bla.
Und das ist jetzt eine IT-Service-Administrator sogar.
Administrativer Arbeiten.
Sag mal.
Okay.
stellenanzeige die klingt so 08 15 generiert dass ich fast wetten könnte
das hat irgend irgendein typ geschrieben für das bis zum trier und die nicht
selber administrative arbeit in einem komplexen it umfeld derzeit circa 3000
anwender microsoft 365 netzwerke windows ok es gibt ja schon ein paar sachen wo
ich auf gar keinen fall was mit zu tun haben will
eines ist active directory ja das zweite sap und dann wenn ich noch also mit
escher habe ich ja keine schmerzen aber windows active directory sap microsoft
das klingt für mich nach was wo ich ganz viel abstand halten halten muss ich
meine ich wurde ja unter anderem in meinem vorstellungsgespräch gefragt herr
max was müssten wir machen dass sie so richtig aufregt war wirklich war eine
eins zu eins frage in meinem vorstellungsgespräch
meine antwort var windows administrieren und das hat sich nicht geändert dh da
hätte ich auch gar keinen bock drauf sicherstellung des it-betriebs gemeinsam
mit unserem engagierten team weiterentwickeln der systemlandschaft
durchführung von projektaufgaben konstruktive mitarbeit bei der
trick umsatz eines anforderungen management das ist so richtig ich das
sind so business niemanden bei dem ich was chances ich weis nicht ob da in peoples
sind so business niemand okay wie sage ich das jetzt am besten also guck mal
wenn ihr euch überlegt oder meint ihr es gibt irgendjemand wenn ihr den fragt was
würdest du was würdest du gerne in deinem traum job machen dass bei
irgendjemand in der it ja ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen bwl 3 hat
leuten irgendjemand der in der it arbeitet ja und dann fragst du was was
was gehörten zu deinen traum tätigkeit dass da ihr auch dass da auch nur einer
sagen würde ja ganz gar ganz klar konstruktive
mitarbeit bei der entwicklung und umsetzung des anforderungsmanagement das
stelle ich mir vor das würde ich gerne machen
das ist so so nicht greifbarer bullshit satz einfach nur das schreiben total
viele sowas in der richtung unterstützung des second level supports
ok seine fachlichen und persönlichen qualifikationen ok ausbildung abschluss
studium
du würdest gerne daily scrum machen in meinem traum schloss ok da würde ich
auch gerne machen also ganz ehrlich ich hätte gern einen job wo mein einziger job
ist daily scrum zu machen nachdem daily scrum ja definitionstechnisch nicht
länger als sagen wir mal 20 25 30 minuten sein kann wäre das ein super job
sehr gute administrative kenntnisse im bereich cloud computing insbesondere
microsoft 365 das ist übrigens office 365 das wurde vor eine weile umbenannt
also falls ihr euch fragt was es ist das ist office in usa ps4 habe geemer weg
alter netzwerke linux server also die zwei sachen sind schon äußerst breit
gefasst ich kenne auch niemand der das gut kann und dann auch linux server kann
linux sorgs wieder es ist wieder alles klar
sap netzwerk linux server windows für server modern workplace was auch immer
dokumenten management systeme weil es da ja auch nur eins gibt begeisterung für
technik und interesse an neuen technologien ok bla bla bla bla kommen
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla was wir bieten
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt täglicher gottesdienst oder sowas kommt jetzt
bestimmt spannende und abwechslungsreiche arbeit am dynamischen
umfeld inklusive das ist ja nicht so geil klingt sehr 0815 ja eine attraktive
vergütung diese formulierung die müsste mal echt irgendjemand bannen jeder
schreibt das und das ist so nichts sagen einfach nur eine attraktive vergütung
nach den bestimmungen der kirchlichen arbeit und vergütungsordnung kfo
entsprechend deiner qualifikation
ok wir gucken mal kurz was da so drin steht die kirchliche arbeit und sehr
schöne sei ort die seite ist ja richtig exquisite weil es auch am darkreader
liegen könnte ok es liegt am darkreader aber ganz ehrlich ohne darkreader ist es
mir einfach zu anstrengend
entgelt tabelle ja gut wir haben halt absolut keine ahnung wie man da
eingruppiert wird das sagt halt gar nichts aber ich glaube das ist ein guter
tabell ja stimmt dann zuια okay kto bis exposed hat no influenza t Bildung
flache Hierarchie Ak Ruven
wie sieht's mit Homeoffice aus?
zusatzversorgung
arbeitsplatz an dem auch gelebter Glaube einen platz hat
wisst ihr was ich glaube für Leute denen das wichtig ist ist das ein enorm
großer Pluspunkt im einige kennt mich mir ist das scheißegal bei mir ist will
Glaube ähnlich viel zu machen ich bin ich bin nicht so der curved Typ.
Aber wenn das für jemand einen höheren Stellenwert in seinem Leben hat, ist das, glaube ich, ein echt großer Pluspunkt.
Wenn es dir egal ist, würdest du dann dort arbeiten?
Also wenn die...
Naja, nee, würde ich nicht, weil der Job spricht mich nicht an und ich glaube, die Bezahlung ist auch nicht sonderlich gut.
Aber wenn mich der Job ansprechen würde und die ordentlich bezahlen, warum nicht?
Aber ich finde es nicht ansprechend hier.
Null.
Die werden sich hüten, sich in dieser Richtung zu äußern, weil das sicherlich schwierig ist.
Wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob das vielleicht für ein Bistum noch okay ist, wenn die sagen, wir nehmen nur Leute quasi unserer Glaubensrichtung.
Keine Ahnung, ob das erlaubt ist oder nicht.
Bei Jobs in der Kirche ist das okay.
Okay, ja, habe ich mir fast schon gedacht, dass es da Ausnahmen gibt.
Also super, so spannend finde ich das jetzt nicht.
Aber wisst ihr was?
Das ist immer noch besser als der MacOS-Admin.
Chat, was?
Okay.
Ich weiß, das ist jetzt keine...
Beides keine so gute Alternativen, aber...
Wo würdet ihr lieber arbeiten?
Beim Bistum?
Oder als MacOS-Admin in Hamburg?
Sorry, über den Dächern Hamburgs.
Würdest du lieber Klübien tauschen, ja, tatsächlich?
Dann lieber Hartz IV.
Heißt das nicht Bürger gelten jetzt?
Geharzt wird nicht mehr.
Bistrum.
Okay, einen haben wir noch.
Chat, ich hoffe, ich habe...
Ich habe sonst nichts übersehen.
Moment, C++-Entwickler.
Oh, jetzt kommt meine Traumstelle, Leute, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, jetzt ist es soweit.
Da habe ich drauf gewartet.
CGM, MonkaS, wieso sagt mir gar nichts?
Okay, Chat.
Chat kennt die anscheinend und meint die Taugen nix.
CGM, Medistar, Systemhaus.
Ich sage mir überhaupt gar nichts.
Softwareentwickler, C++, cute.
E-Health.
Da willst du nicht hin.
Nee, ich will da eh nicht hin.
Aber die verwenden das einzig Gute, was man mit C++ machen kann.
CompuCrew Medical.
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Das skippen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Ja.
Development is your passion.
Unser Produkt ist Medistar.
Das meistinstallierte Arztinformationssystem auf dem deutschen Markt.
Ich glaube, das hat mein Zahnarzt auch.
Mein Zahnarzt war letztens übelst am flamen über die Lizenzbedingungen von seinem, ja, wahrscheinlich Arztinformationssystem.
Als Mitglied unserer...
Ah, jetzt geht's los, Leute.
Jetzt wird diagonal...
Hyper, Agile, Mikrosprint-basiertes, T-Shaped, Safe Kanban durchgeführt.
Als Mitglied unseres agilen Teams Scrum bist du maßgeblich an der Weiterentwicklung unserer frühen Produkte.
Unsere Ziele, die Prozesse in der App...
Okay, bla, bla, bla.
Alter, wie viel Geschwätze, Mann.
Kommt da irgendwann nochmal was.
Du entwickelst neue Module mit cute in C++ und bindest externe Produkte über APIs an.
Aber behältst du die Kunden...
Okay, ja.
Also, User-Stories, ja.
Also, wer das nicht kennt, User-Stories sind zum Beispiel sowas wie...
Ich bin Arzt und möchte möglichst viel für meine Arztsoftware bezahlen.
Das wäre eine User-Story.
Oder...
Real...
Ups, jetzt mal realistischer.
Ja.
Ist das sowas wie...
Ich bin Arzt und möchte...
Ähm...
Ja, Patientenreihenfolge im Wartezimmer möglichst reibungslos abwickeln oder sowas.
User-Stories, das ist immer so ein Spruch drum.
Ähm...
So ein Wort dafür.
So, wenn man das, wenn man das, wenn man quasi Anforderungen aus Anwendersicht so formuliert.
Ich kann das besser, ich kann das nicht besser beschreiben.
Könnt ihr das besser beschreiben?
Im Prinzip ist das, was die Anwender...
wollen, ist mit User-Stories gemeint.
Du entwirfst Entwicklungskonzepte für Business-Logik, UI und Datenbankstrukturen kennen.
Das ist eine schöne User-Story, genau.
Als Q-Chat möchte ich mehr über C++-Friends hören, um mir vollumfänglich ein Bild zu machen, warum ich C++ nicht verwenden möchte.
Korrekt.
Das wäre eine User-Story.
Genauso sehen die Dinger immer aus.
Aber mehr, weniger lang.
Es muss möglichst vage und nichtssagend sein.
Ja, das ist auch ganz wichtig, dass am Ende rauskommen kann, was will.
Bei der Gelegenheit fällt mir immer dieses Bild ein, was ihr sicherlich alle kennt.
Dieses, was der Kunde will, was der Architekt sich ausgedacht hat, was der Programmierer programmiert hat.
Ihr kennt das, ne, mit der Schaukel.
Mit der Schaukel und dem Reifen.
Das kennt jeder, das Bild.
Ultimate Code.
Du entwirfst Entwicklungskonzepte...
Qualität und Team-Spirit.
Das bringst du mit IT-Background.
C++, Qt, SQL.
Kommunikation ist, du kennst das Ganze, Sinn und Zweck.
Werdet Teil einer wichtigen Mission.
Ja, kommt drauf an.
Die wichtige Mission sollte auch sein, ordentlich Geld auf dem Konto.
Ich finde, das ist erstmal, wenn man einen Job macht, so eine der wichtigsten Missionen.
Eine Schnittstelle von Gesundheitswesen, bla bla bla bla.
Gestaltungsspielraum, bla bla bla bla.
Boah, das ist eine super krasse Resident-Sleeper-Stellenanzeige.
Die finde ich null ansprechend.
Und, ehrlich, mich interessiert der Bereich aber auch gar nicht.
Vielleicht, vielleicht würde das noch Pluspunkte machen.
Ich finde die super langweilig.
Außerdem fehlt der Obstkorb, ja.
Stimmt.
Ohne Obstkorb geht nix.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie die Leute mit 50k abspeisen.
Weil, C++, Qt-Entwickler, ich glaube, so wie Sand am Meer gibt es die auch nicht.
Ich vermute mal, dass Bezahlung tatsächlich eines...
eines der wenigen, ganz guten Punkte hier in der Stelle, also, dafür ist.
Vielleicht ist der Laden auch super geil und...
Aber ich finde, dass die Stellenanzeige, finde ich super langweilig.
So.
Mauriz hat ein neues Video, guckt man es an.
C++-Tutorial in 60 Minuten.
Nein, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Oh mein Gott!
Kein C++, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Ja.
Die schlechtesten Chefs aller Zeiten.
Na ja.
Wir haben jetzt ein paar...
Was ist das hier?
Einfach, einfach...
Original.
Muss man einfach mal draufklicken.
Aber als geht.
Chatge...
Punktlandung.
So pünktlich waren wir noch nie fertig.
Moin, bisschen off-topic.
Aber wie wichtig findest du sich ab für die Physio-Ausbildung?
Gar nicht.
Kommt auf deinen Job an und was du in der Berufsschule machst.
Wenn du in deinem Job nichts mit .NET und C Sharp machst und in der Berufsschule das nicht auf dem Plan steht, ist das komplett...
Ja.
Nicht relevant für dich.
Es sei denn, es interessiert dich und du möchtest gerne damit was machen.
Das ist ja wieder was anderes.
Wir gucken jetzt kein Video.
Ich geh jetzt gleich ins Bett.
Gleich ins Bett gehen.
Ihr wisst, Boomer müde.
Boomer schlafen.
Kommt auch auf den Betrieb an. Es gibt sehr viele...
Läden, die machen auch .NET.
Dann brauchst du natürlich C Sharp.
Kommt auf die Stelle.
Ich persönlich...
Ich weiß, dass C Sharp meine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache ist.
Also ich find's natürlich top.
Aber für meinen Job brauch ich's im Prinzip auch nicht.
Es ist aber gut, dass ich's kann.
Ich hab schon die ein oder anderen .NET Sachen gebastelt.
Für den aktuellen Job noch nicht.
Aber...
Also auf meiner alten Arbeit...
Ich hab letztens erst mit einem geredet.
Laufen auf jeden Fall noch ein paar .NET Programme von mir.
Kümmert sich jetzt zwar keiner mehr drum.
Aber die laufen anscheinend.
Die machen Java in der Berufsschule.
Ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Mal davon abgesehen, dass es Java ist.
Aber es könnte schlimmer sein.
Es könnte C++ sein.
Also wenn du willst...
Also wenn die in der Berufsschule dafür sorgen wollen,
dass die Leute niemals wieder in ihrem Leben programmieren wollen,
dann lass sie mit C++ anfangen.
Es kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Was willst du machen?
Slicks.
Nee. Slick. Irgendwie. So.
Was willst du machen?
Das ist komplett...
Welche Sprache und welche Technologie du lernen solltest,
ist ganz entscheidend davon abhängig,
was du machen willst.
Oder was dein Betrieb benutzt.
Ja.
Wenn du einfach nur
ein bisschen Programmieren lernen möchtest,
dann ist meiner Ansicht nach
das Einfachste zum Einsteigen
Visual Studio Code runterladen,
JavaScript, CSS, HTML.
Da siehst du visuell, was passiert
und die Einstiegshörenden,
die ich jetzt hier machen würde,
ist quasi nicht existent.
Weil jeder hat einen Browser bei sich auf der Kiste.
Ja, Pascal.
Pascal war beliebt, genauso wie Delphi.
Wobei, ist nicht das eine irgendwie
aus dem anderen entstanden sogar?
Das machen sehr viele Mathelehrer.
Also Leute,
die früher Mathe unterrichtet haben
und jetzt ein bisschen Proggas Zeug unterstützen.
Äh, bisschen Proggas Zeug unterrichten.
Die machen gerne Pascal
und Delphi und so Zeug.
Aber die sind auch schon
irgendwie 60 plus
und bald in Rente.
Delphi nicht die Idee?
Nee, oder?
Was, ernsthaft?
Das wird aber abgedreht langsam.
Kann ich mir auch vorstellen.
Das ist zur Zeit eines der angesagtesten
Technologien
so in der
gerade, also
gerade im Thema AI
kommst du um Python eigentlich kaum drum herum.
Natürlich immer noch
eine Sache, was du machen willst, ja.
Und gerade so
im Science-Bereich ist es auch sehr beliebt.
Placingly, aber nur wenn es
Placingly fast ist.
Also ich würde dir empfehlen,
nimm JavaScript.
Da ist die Einstiegshürde
einfach die kleinste.
Und man sieht visuell was, wenn man im Browser
was macht. Wenn du natürlich gar keinen
Bock hast auf,
also wenn du gar nichts mit Web-Entwicklung am Hut
haben willst, dann nicht, aber Web-Entwicklung
so ein bisschen Ahnung von JavaScript
HTML und CSS
bringt dir immer was, dein komplettes
Leben lang.
Ich denke schon, dass er Java meint.
Ja stimmt, vielleicht meint er auch JavaScript.
Kann sein. Also ich würde, wie gesagt,
JavaScript zum Einstärken
empfehlen.
Python mag die schönere Sprache sein,
aber JavaScript
ist die Einstiegshürde noch geringer.
Man kann mit JavaScript auch irgendwie
alles machen, wobei natürlich schon
sagen wir so Web-Entwicklung
die hauptsächlichen Einsatzgebiete
sind. Trotzdem mit
Elektron kannst du auch Desktop-Anwendungen bauen.
Wenn du möchtest, dass
dein Hello World
450 MB RAM braucht.
Ja.
So sieht's aus.
Und JavaScript ist mittlerweile
auch eine ganz gute Sprache.
Die haben komische Dinger, ja, gleich, gleich,
gleich und
not a number is not a number und sowas.
Aber insgesamt hat
JavaScript das geschafft, was C++
vergeblich versucht hat die letzten
Jahre über, ja.
C++ war
ne weirdchamp hoch 10
Sprache und das ist es
immer noch, nur mit noch mehr
weirdchamp hoch 15
neuen Sachen dabei.
Und JavaScript ist auch super
weirdchamp, aber
hat sich viel
verbessert die letzten Jahre.
Und viele neue sinnvolle
Sachen dabei und auch, sag mal,
logisch integrierte Sachen.
So, Leute.
Ich geh jetzt
pennen.
Wir sehen uns die Tage. Morgen muss ich echt mal wieder ein Video
aufnehmen. Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.